zach when did you start writing
screenplays i started in uh nya film
school um
so
a while ago
but um it was actually i wrote my first
it wasn't i was writing short scripts in
film school and then um my first script
i wrote right after i graduated
and that was part of your thesis was to
do these shorts no um so
we were more i wasn't in the dramatic
writing program at nyu we were
in
the film production tv production uh
major so to speak we focused more on
producing directing um we did obviously
take a writing class or two
but um that was more sort of geared
towards short
short films that we would shoot
ourselves or produce
or at that time video you know we had
the tv production
um
but for the most part no i didn't i had
always been curious about writing but i
really and when i got to once i got out
of film school and through film school i
really developed
a affinity for
writing and editing and um you were sort
of the
beginning of the process and the end the
process but i always thought
the most creative parts of the process
of making films or making television
so
you know again it was mostly short stuff
through film school but then when i got
out i started thinking alright let me
give that this writing thing a go and i
wrote my first script
so
uh
i think i had started on it maybe during
film school but then once i was out
right when i finished
after graduation i finished it and after
graduation did you stay in new york city
for about a year uh i i worked some jobs
and um you know i had my family was
there and i had a girlfriend at the time
who i was very serious with and
once um i sort of realized that new york
wasn't the place to be and that you know
i had spoken to some um
friends of mine and and uh fellow
tisch alum who were out on the west
coast
you know it became clear that i needed
to to move to move out here to la and
and start my film career
this is where everyone and everything
was at the time
it's since changed a lot and involved
but back then that's when it uh became
clear that you know new york really
wasn't
happening uh on the grand scale that you
know or to further my career at the time
in the film and tv business so i moved
and when you came here uh did you have
any sort of not buyer's remorse but did
you did you have a couple sleepless
nights where you said maybe this isn't
for me
you know i don't remember i think i you
know i have i was very fortunate because
both my parents were very supportive in
my decision um you know they had both
been advertising executives and both
kind of always marched to their own beat
so they wanted you know they wanted me
to sort of pursue my goals career goals
and so
moving here
i definitely felt that
i had their support i've missed them
very much
but no i don't think i ever
had any sleepless nights i at times i
thought oh maybe i will move back one
day because i did miss new york but
after a while i just became accustomed
to la and and realized that i was more
probably while new york was always home
i always felt that you know
my soul belonged here in california and
los angeles
how many screenplays did you write
before you wrote take back well i wrote
take back
probably in the year of 2012 so before
that i had written
probably about ten
i'd say anywhere from eight to ten off
the top of my head
so um
yeah it was um
interesting story it was my
manager at the time
suggested i write something
a low-budget action film
and
[Music]
i
believe it or not
was in church
i attended this church service once and
um
[Music]
this woman was speaking about she was um
she ran this worldwide organization that
helped women and helped them recover and
you know build their lives back
and i just remember i literally had the
conversation with my my manager like
suggesting i write a low budget action
film
and
[Music]
um
this
you know sermon
you know literally a week later i'm like
oh that's interesting and it kind of
went from there um
[Music]
but um but yeah it was it was a um i
would say uh
probably a good eight to ten scripts
before i i wrote take back and these
were feature scripts yeah they were
feature i had written some
uh i had no i hadn't quite started doing
pilots i
i had i had written i subsequently wrote
some pilots um but this was my first um
uh yeah this was um
yeah everything else had been features
up until that point
and so were you using a screenwriting
software when you started these eight to
ten scripts or were you doing it just
sort of like in a word document page no
i always i always used final draft uh i
think back in film school and or and and
maybe my first uh script i used what was
called i think it was called script
thing it was an nyu professor of mine
he had all it was final draft i think
was still was around at the time i'm
pretty sure but he had us using script
thing and
you know um you know it was fine it was
just like final draft but you know and i
don't even know if it's still around i'm
assuming it's not but after that i went
to final draft
but i always
um i always
plot my story on word doc i always
structure plan everything um on my word
document on word doc before i go into uh
the actual writing of the script and
that could take
you know months before i feel
comfortable with you know that that
blueprint before i put it uh before i go
and start actually writing you know
action and dialogue
was take back your original script yes
take back was the original script um
and again you know just it was um i
should say inspired by
this story and i'll give you the the
story that i heard was there this this
um
this woman who ran this worldwide
organization that helped girls she had
heard about this
or had taken in this young woman
who i think was about maybe 18 or 19 at
the time and she was dating this guy
and
she was dating this man for a few months
and
one night he took her to like this bar
and
um she was subsequently uh drugged
and then this was in st louis
and she woke up in this just sort of
very decrepit
you know abandoned warehouse somewhere
with other girls
and
was basically kept there for i think
three to four years
yeah and it was
this horrific story
where she was kept there and
as
miracle would have it uh one day her
captor you know or one of her captors
i guess left the key near her because
she was basically chained to a bed three
or four years and john's would come in
and
you know
do their thing and
she was um chained to this bed and
miraculously
this key dropped i guess one of the
captors key to her cuffs dropped on the
bed or near the bed she got it
freed herself and escaped and alerted
the cops and
so that was really sort of after that
was the the story that sort of drove me
to you know write the script like if
there was this woman who was
taken held and then basically she wound
up escaping and taking revenge on her
trying to live a normal life
her past came back to haunt her
in the form of the man who
kidnapped her who she thought was dead
and then you know she's got a basically
now she has this family that she has to
protect
so
that was sort of the um the bare bones
for the story that i i came up with and
you know again subsequently went through
a number of drafts till it got to
the shooting version
does your process change every time you
write a screenplay or has it evolved or
sometimes you'll do it one way and
you'll plot and you'll outline and other
times you'll start another way great
question and i know everyone has a
different process about when you're
developing a script or an idea um for me
i i feel like i've gotten
that old adage of um you know work
smarter not harder
i think that ultimately boils down to
knowing to having a really solid
the first process is getting the log
line down where you have that the log
line and you have that hint of irony
it's it's um
you know um
just
you know boiling it down to a sentence
that you can pitch to somebody like
what's it about and
you know people get it right away um
[Music]
from there once i think you have that
locked in
then it's a matter of really breaking it
out into um
you know the main components of the
story and the structure for me that is
where i've really become a lot more
fastidious with my process of you know
knowing
like again what's the hard turn what's
the you know what's that inciting
incident how does it affect the
character what's sending them off to
that to that first act turn point
turning point then from there
to the bin point and then
intact three and how they're changing
along the way
um i think it was
you know i was uh i'm sure like every
writer
you know obviously read the blake snyder
you know save the cat and i think
honestly that's that's
probably the most uh comprehensive book
on screenwriting i i would i recommend
that anyone who's looking to
break in i always tell them to get you
know save the cat save the cat goes to
the movies because i think blake snyder
was really on to something um
so
i really do follow i believe it's the 16
major beats that he laid out in there
and and you know their purpose and
for me that really i think
you know i was going in that direction
before i read the blake snyder novel but
certainly after and and and he was also
such an inspiring writer um uh blake
snyder was
but getting a good idea of you know how
to
you know really lay out the story and
how to structure it
that to me is
is again is the most important part of
the process you know i think once you
have your log line and your structure
you know
you know the writing it's probably about
60 70 percent of the process i think the
actual writing is about 30 percent you
know because if you everything lined up
you know where your character is going
you know their journey
um it's going to make things a lot
easier for you um and of course things
will always change and you have to be
open and flexible i know some people who
write 30 page outlines
40 page outlines i usually try to keep
it between 6 and 8 pages
um just because i feel like
if you're
with an outline like that you sort of
lose some of the momentum the creativity
where if you have a good idea and you're
you really have a good structure in
place knowing you know what what scene
comes after what scene comes after what
scene and it's this you know
snowball that keeps rolling up
um
you know if you keep it tight in those
first in that that outline and then
from there you can use that and then
just transfer it to
uh
the final final draft or the actual
script you know i think then you have
good momentum um
to keep to keep the flow the creative
flow going for sure and giving leaving
yourself room for some flexibility
because things will always come up
and um
certainly has in anything that i've ever
written
and how long did you work on the log
line for take back um
the log line um
that one actually came
fairly
quickly i don't recall because it's been
some time but i think once
i think after really sort of attending
that particular church service it it
came pretty quickly and you know again i
pitched it to my manager at the time and
gave him a very like you know bare-bones
idea where i wanted the story to go
and she said yeah go for it
it you know he was always mine he still
is my barometer and um uh of of
you know we still throw ideas off you
know uh the wall at each other and and i
think it he definitely was instrumental
in you know giving me um
uh
you know good um
sort of uh good feedback on the log line
and then where the story was going to go
do you remember the exact log line
the exactly
um well i remember the i remember the
quick elevator pitch was always going to
be taken it was going to be taken meets
a history of violence i i always loved
a history of violence for
um
i just thought it was it was based on a
graphic novel but i loved
you know the idea of this guy who is
you know
he's he's living this very seemingly
quiet life in the middle of america
and he commits this act of heroism
and then his past comes back to get him
and we're still not sure is it really
him and then you know we i i don't know
if anyone is seated i want to spoil the
movie but it really was for me i i
basically saw it as if
to be as simplistic as possible a female
version of a history of violence
um so it was i i guess at the time again
this is going back a few years the
original log line would have been
something like you know
you know a young woman living a
seemingly you know
happy existence in this small town
commits commits act of heroism that
brings
uh evil forces from her her past life if
you will
will you ever write a screenplay without
outlining first no
um i know
and uh
you know again my my process is i have
my process you know it's
um a lot of people
have their way of doing things some
people can just i've known writers
who've been successful who are just able
to they have it in their head and
they're just able to
you know put it down on paper write go
right to final draft and put it on paper
now for me i have to be again i really
have to know how those beats turn those
the main beats turn into story
um and really what my character's
journey is and where they start and
where they end and
you know i know it seems pretty uh
rudimentary but it's it's really
for me yeah i don't i don't think i
could ever do that i would be lost you
know
um
you know there's uh
as i'm sure a lot of your viewers know
you've you've heard of second act tell
where you
you know you could write a great first
act
but then just get your character gets
completely lost in the second act and
that that more ass that when you haven't
been when you haven't plotted it on this
again this just applies to me
you know
um
knowing really where
where they're supposed to go um you have
to be their their guide you have to be
the character's guide
um
and if you don't know if you don't have
again like some kind of blueprint and
play blue blueprint in place
you know it's not going to again this is
in my opinion it it doesn't it doesn't
help me
um again there's there's as i said
earlier there's i always find you can i
try to be as flexible as possible the
story especially after you've written it
and you get feedback from you know
colleagues
you know and others um you know and
sometimes a script may just not work and
you may write it and you think you know
this isn't
this isn't cutting it i have to go back
and you know um re-examine and and maybe
rip it apart and try it again
um
and sometimes you just have to move on
it may just not be the right time you
may get inspired by another idea
um but yeah the the i would never i
would never not outline um
uh any kind of writing i do i always
have to have a blueprint in place
is discipline and order something that
you actually enjoy yes
um
you know i try to write
anywhere between four and six hours a
day i think after sometimes longer it
depends i can go you know eight to ten
hours
um before i start really
i think six hours is pretty much where
is my average where i can just you know
i can go to before i start you know i'm
like i think my brain is i need to just
throw in the towel for the day
um but yes no i'm usually up pretty
early
um you know um
usually writing i'd say anywhere between
seven and eight
you know and then i'll work to the late
morning
uh take a breath break do a little
exercise
um
you know have breakfast and then
work again until the early evening
that's generally my structure
um
and you know abided by that for a while
i know you talked about martial arts
yeah and that's something that's part of
your life yeah i know martial arts is a
big part of my life and um
i've been do i've been training for you
know over 10 years and you know this
sort of
ties into you know everyone's process is
different you know it was always this
um not so much in our
community but in in other i've heard of
other you know
people who train in martial arts saying
you know one might be better than the
other and
you know if you're doing if you're doing
some martial art
it's great because i feel like they're
so wonderful for the mental physical and
spiritual side of someone to help them
um
you know as it is with writing everyone
has their own process and
you know
whatever it might be whatever it might
however
you do something or however you feel is
and if that works for you
then god bless um
but um but yeah and again as far as
martial arts yes i think martial arts is
wonderful for discipline
for self-esteem
um
and
you know
you're also
you know really i think tapping into
similar
emotions sometimes as you are with
writing you know there's there is
definitely a um
a spiritual side i think to um to
martial arts and
i think as it is with writing you know
you're getting in touch with certain
emotions uh in a spiritual sense
creative sense um
and um if that makes any that makes any
sense
um but yeah i i feel that in a lot of
ways they you know they run um
and there's a parallel to both of them
for sure one helps the other
right speaking of spiritual i think the
writer of the exorcist and forgive me
i'm blanking on his name and i enjoy
was it william peter blotti yes i think
so i bought it right and he said there's
a rhythm or was that the writer of
straws
i don't know i read i read the exorcist
and i read jaws you know
the books i think it was william peter
blotti who wrote the exorcist i thought
so yeah and he said and and he was a
very spiritual man and he said that that
there was a
good writing has a rhythm yeah and i was
wondering if if there's almost a
correlation between that and then the
martial arts because you're you're
getting into some sort of a flow
absolutely um you know
for me
you know aside from the joy that i get
from my wife and my uh
my daughter and my stepchildren there
are um
and family
[Music]
uh when new york sports teams are
actually good
um there's a there's a there's
definitely a um
a high i get from from writing
when you're investing a character and
you're really pushing their story and
you're locked in and you're your
character almost speaking for you
um
and i've i've heard a lot of other
writers talk about that and i think
early in my career i'm like you know
what what are you talking about but i
think after you've done it for a while
and you
again have a good
sense of where again you have a good
structure in place and you know where
your story is going
the characters in a sense will start
talking for you you know what you know
where they they know you stop leading
them and they start leading you in a way
which is which is pretty neat and i
think that is what
for me what we hope to achieve and
martial arts absolutely
there are breakthroughs when you're
in tungsuda which is my martial art we
have um
[Music]
we do we perform youngs which are
essentially
you know improvised fighting forms
um
and there's something to be said when
you really reach that
level when you're really connected when
your mind body and spirit
are all connected
it's it's again it's that that just that
rush of euphoria that you really
and and it is a blend of creativity and
it's a blend of discipline it's a it's a
blend of focus
that all comes together and it's
it's you you really derive a triumphant
feeling from it
there's no doubt and uh you know
it's
i know that
you know again if i if i leave
the office and i'm i'm really thrilled
with something i wrote i
i have a bounce of my step similar
martial arts if i really feel like i got
to form down well
and then of course are the days where
you're like you know
i didn't have i wasn't really on it
you know and i'm i'm one to beat myself
up although i've gotten better thanks to
martial arts about not beating myself as
up as much as i used to
but there's definitely there there's
definitely links sure and again in my
opinion between the two and i've been
doing both for a long time
we were joking off camera while setting
up that you don't have to be the writer
that has like several scotches and his
chances
you know you can be the discipline
writer that's like you said up yeah at
five and having whatever chai or
yeah no it's funny yeah that story i was
yeah it was um
that story derived from the fact that my
you know my late dad um
you know he uh it was actually we were
having a discussion shortly before he
passed away
um
uh he was uh
i told him that i was uh going out with
some friends too you know we were gonna
have some scotch and smoke some cigars
which was a mistake because my dad
you know my dad said he said oh god he
said i could just see you in your
apartment there writing you know with a
bottle of scotch and and you know cigar
going all night and
you know and that to me that's i'm not a
big drinker i rarely smoke cigars
but uh yeah that's sort of the um
you know i guess almost like a parody of
writers from the you know that or or
stigma of writers maybe that still
exists like my dad was probably
old-fashioned in some ways
uh but those writers from the that that
uh bygone era of the
the golden era film as they said 30s 40s
50s you know up in their little uh
you know um
uh
i guess what were they um bungalows uh
you know writing until all odd hours of
the night you know drinking scotch
smoking cigarettes or cigars
but no i
you know my my process is you know two
cups of coffee and uh you know
through the day and i'm good
no alcohol infusion or or cigarettes or
cigars
so yeah yeah
what's your typical writing day
usually i i tend to get up um
anywhere between
you know maybe
quarter to six 6 30. um
you know again i i
try not to wake my wife um
and you know i i get that cup of coffee
to get my fix my caffeine fix and then
um i'm usually uh
writing in our we have a guest small
guesthouse i'm usually in the back there
um for me i like i enjoy reading the
newspaper in the morning for about 30
minutes just to get my brain sort of
drinking coffee getting my brain going
just
i'm an avid reader i always have been um
and i feel like reading really starts
you know
stimulating the mind along with the
caffeine
um but it gets me going so um
yeah i usually so again i try to be
working by about 7 30 or 8 o'clock
and um
again until you know i'll work to the
late morning uh take a break just to get
my head right and then come back and you
know probably the early afternoon and
you know i can go till late afternoon
sometimes um
so that's usually my that's usually in
my routine as you said be you know asked
before is that it's there's definitely
there's a rhythm
to the rhythm
uh i feel especially when i'm when i'm
writing and creating
and when you say you're reading the
paper is this an actual newspaper yes i
i know i have um i have friends and my
wife still joke me i i do have some
traditions that i have not parted ways
with and yes it's a it's a
it is a actual paper
i try to i really try to avoid the
screen as much as i can um because i'm
on it all day um so yeah when i can uh
usually get you know you know anything
in in print
uh it makes just to start my day you
know to get again get those juices
flowing get my brain working
i find that writing really or reading
excuse me really helps the writing for
sure and again doing it not on a screen
are you reading the first pages of this
uh yeah it's usually i may i'm a
longtime um
uh wall street journal fan and i i
happen to read you know pretty much you
know everything throughout um
[Music]
i you know i'm a fan of their reportage
i think it's pretty much down the middle
i know not to get into
you know we're a very divided country
right now but i i
happen to really
appreciate the fact that they're fairly
down the middle and not too biased
one way or the other
um
and for me that's you know that's
important so yeah i mean knowing what's
going on in the world
and in our country uh again um
[Music]
as has really really helps
me and i think helps my writing because
you know you never know where that next
idea is coming from i think a lot of my
ideas over the years have come from you
know magazines or or articles in the
paper uh not necessarily wall street
journal i read all kinds of i used to
read news magazines um
[Music]
i wrote a script about a militia group
um
[Music]
that was um
[Music]
uh
derived from a i believe it was a
newsweek article
you know in my
chiropractor at the time her office uh
she had this newsweek article on the
rise of militias uh probably this was
around 2010 or so
so i i wrote another i wrote another
script about a um a pirate hunter in the
southeast asia which was based on a um
smithsonian article
so i always find and i've i've had
i had another idea for a script that was
based on
a story recently in the wall street
journal so
that's where i derive a lot of my my
ideas from um when i'm writing uh when
i'm from my film ideas anyway and then
of course you know take back was hearing
something in a sermon but
you know it was um
uh it was a i guess it i i it's a news
related type
story um so i always found that
finding stories in the news you know um
you know again it it
i've i've known people that have just
been able to conjure up
great stories in their mind um and i've
done that a couple times but i feel like
for me just reading about someone and
again this is not you know
you know stealing the article or
anything it's just coming up like oh
that's an interesting topic and then you
know sort of making it my own it wasn't
never necessarily articles about a
particular person it was about
a particular subject and and
you know that definitely helped um
definitely help me you know develop my
own stories and give me that sort of
that germ of the idea to then
take it in the direction i wanted to and
make it my own
who do you model your screenwriting
after
um
i don't
model it after anyone per se i i've been
i definitely have some people of
influence who i think are phenomenal
writers and obviously their track record
speaks for themselves themselves but
i've always
been um
you know obviously william goldman who
you know he's the godfather
of screenwriting um
tony gilroy brian helgeland um
david capp those guys
you know
when you read one of their scripts i
mean they're just on a whole other level
and
um
you know i was i was always especially
um
uh you know i would say
tony gilroy especially because i feel
like he writes
uh some just brilliant action
and
um
yeah those those uh those screenwriters
i think for me
were you know set he definitely left a
an impression and you know how to write
just an entertaining script because
i think sometimes you know
the way i try to write is that i want
people to keep turning pages i know this
might be you know the process for many
writers or what they set out to do but i
really do think it's important is after
all you know you want your you want your
audience to
keep going
um and i've always believed in just
being as sparse
um and concise as possible in my
descriptions and
you know letting the dialogue move the
story along and not
getting so so wrapped up in
you know smart ass
dialogue but just letting the characters
again take the story in the direction
and drive drive the story especially if
you're writing action or or adventure or
thriller type you know genre films
do you ever subscribe to the idea i know
some people have said don't don't delve
too much into one
artist's work because then you might end
up emulating them too much
and you wouldn't even realize it or or
no there is definitely some truth to
that you know um
reading reading a whole
a whole array of
of scripts and writers definitely helps
inform you better i i feel like for some
of the scripts that i wrote
i always you know again
um
you know if i'm if i'm if somebody's to
write an action script and they want
somebody to just sort of again to be a a
guy to somebody a reference
for them i would i would always say look
at a gilroy a helga land or a david kept
script because again i feel like they're
you know
i should say that for me pacing is
really important i want to keep the
story moving along at a fluid pace and i
feel like those guys like um another
steve's alien
steve's alien i remember
said something that that
left a le has has left a lasting
impression i read this years ago where
he said
i will cut and cut and cut until if i
cut one again i'm paraphrasing here i
cut one
word
the whole scene falls apart
so just being able to really
make your scenes as lean as possible and
in your writing and to keep it paced and
to keep it moving forward and keep the
story moving forward the character
moving forward
um
and i and i do think yes i i
it's good i mean you know read read all
tony gilroy scripts but obviously i
would suggest reading a whole lot of
other scripts and and getting a sense of
that um
and uh again just just try to
stay true to your voice because it is
easy if you read one particular author
or one particular screenwriter you
definitely could fall in the trap of you
know subconsciously
you're writing like them and i think
again they're good reference points but
you just have to again
find your own voice and find your own
rhythm and pattern
um
and uh you know stay true to that do you
remember the first script that you read
it was probably in the late 90s
and i want to say
it may have been chinatown
it may have been chinatown it's been a
while so
yeah
it may have been chinatown or even um
saving private ryan
which was a
amazing script uh and chinatown
was obviously robert town just one of
the masters as well um but
i think it may have very well been
chinatown where did you get it in 1998
it would have been
it would have been it would have been uh
through nyu we they had a fairly they
had a library that you could go and take
scripts out and read and
um
so that's probably where i got it and i
having
having been had been a fan of
that film growing up and being a k you
know when i was a kid um
you know my mom and dad again were very
liberated they let us get away with
watching
you know what now i think parents you
know maybe over
protect but again the 80s were you know
the 80s were a different time
but um
you know we were my mom and dad you know
exposed us to you know many of the great
movies like i i
might i first watched french connection
which is my favorite film
uh of all time bar none um when i was i
think nine
it was uh running on the um
on the local fox affiliate in new york
and you know my dad had loved that movie
and he said it's a great film and we
watched it commercials and all and it's
funny because i think that summer it may
have been the summer of 87 or 86 it was
on like
probably every other week
it was maybe this is the 80s and they
you know it was a summer film they just
kept running over time
uh over the the course of the summer or
that period of time
um but it was uh
yeah i i really loved it and not long
after that you know we saw the godfather
and and so i think i had probably
seen chinatown and the godfather both
godfather films and in chinatown are in
french connection before i was 10.
so i was exposed to film you know from a
really young age um
and um
[Music]
yeah that was so um
yeah so that was and and
your your question about uh chinatown
was yeah i i probably got that script at
the uh at the nyu library
how did you learn story structure i
learned it in uh initially learned it at
nyu i had a um a screenwriting
profession a professor by the name of
stephen siegel
who
really
you know he was a
he was tough uh but fair
and he was a stickler for
um
not just story structure
but uh format
and
to this day i still have his voice in my
head a little bit
when i'm writing um
i became maybe at times
too wedded to certain formatting
um
but he really taught me the bare bones
of how to write a script um
i think
you know when i was young again it was
that urge just to get to the just to
start writing not to really think about
the story and plot it out
i think it became much clearer to me
about how to
you know again story structure
you know character development as i as i
got older and and got out of film school
but he definitely planted
the seeds
that i then sort of sewed later on as i
again evolved as a writer
when you left film school
did you i know you said that you
realized at some point that new york was
probably not for you at the time right
did you think that you would get a job
working in a production company what was
in your mind that you as a career
yeah um i mean for me it was to just be
in the business and see where you know
the day you know to see where i could go
um i was pretty fortunate because when i
came out here i had a lot of interviews
right away i had so my first job out of
nyu had been at um
writers and artists which is was
purchased by paradigm probably
maybe even 20 years at this point
but they were still like they had a new
york and an la office and they had a a
nice uh stable of like james gandolfini
at the time was rep by them um they had
some other fairly big name actors
um
and the new york the new york agents
erect like they i think they actually
had may have had um
uh half the cast on um sopranos so they
repped a lot of you know broadway and
film tv actors
so i was my first job out of school
when i moved to la
i initially was interviewing at
management companies and other agencies
i knew i didn't want to be an agent but
i thought just getting the
um
experience and learning the business was
most important
um
i i worked at icm for
about a second
it was literally a second it was
probably three days
i worked for a very big talent agent
there and quickly realized that i was
just not gonna cut it um
so
um
my roommate at the time
i was i remember walking out icm and
just
breathing a sigh of relief because
i had
i feel like a monkey had been off my
back so i'm like okay i know there's no
way i'm gonna work in the agency
business at all or mat as a manager you
know that i just can't do it i'm not cut
from that cloth there's a certain type
and i am not
he or she
so
my roommate at the time for whatever
reason he had been sent a job
opportunity as a writer's pa on this
fox show
at the time and i went in and i
interviewed i got the job and then the
first day my first day there the show is
cancelled oh no
so it lasted a couple more weeks and
it was they the same production company
was producing this comedy
and
it was a sitcom that they are they were
developing uh it was an ed burns pilot
and um
i remember because it was the same
company they were saving on supplies so
we brought the supplies from i was at
sony at the time i moved this supplies
to um
uh uh the uh cbs radford and i walked in
i said hey um you guys are starting do
you need a a pa your writer's pa they're
like actually we need a pa and i was
like great here's my resume and i got
the job and i worked for about a month
and i was a night pa
and
i have to say like i've worked some very
interesting jobs but
driving in la
at night
was
just this it was a
it was a
um i i don't want to use the word
mystical but it was it was definitely an
interesting experience you know
because at that time this was just i
mean people had email but a lot of
executives and other writers wanted the
actual script delivered so i was going
from pasadena
to
you know as far out as i may have gone
to malibu and this was like i think i
worked like 27 hours straight but it was
but it was wild it was fun like i
learned the lay of the land
doing that at night it was
i was kind of on my own i was you know
you know driving
probably 80 90 miles an hour in my
little uh
chevy cavalier all around the town
but it was an experience and it was
really it was a lot of fun and
i learned a lot and um anyway
uh long story short that pilot was uh
being shot and i had a friend who was
working at law and order at the time
and he said you know there's a writer's
writer's production assistant job open
on this new law and order show there it
was criminal intent
and they said you are you interested in
i'm like yes i would love to because i
think this this pilot is ending and i
you know they're shooting the pilot it
hadn't been picked up at that point i
was like yes if it's permanent i love it
and i wound up getting that job
and i was a law and art on the law
worked on the law and order shows for
close to two years so
you know i i had that background in
television and then you know from there
um i got into uh to research and i
worked and working at fox for many years
as a research analyst
um while i was still writing and it was
my day job but i always was able to find
jobs that supported my writing and and i
was able to
you know
one fed the other and um
yeah it was it was definitely
back to your question about you know the
business and and getting into it um
[Music]
you know it was
it was definitely i i always knew i
wanted to write
and
the but keeping an open mind on the day
job type led me to in a lot of different
directions and you know i had a time
where i did temp and attempt in
marketing attempt in post-production i
worked in post-production i i had an
array of different jobs and you know
while i was still writing and
you know uh always always putting in the
time and and that's now is has
definitely paid off but um
you know anyone who's coming out and
trying to get in the film business i
would say you know
sign up with a temp agency
you know work in an agency or management
company you may like it maybe writing's
not for you and you may decide you are
cut from that cloth to be an agent
uh but it's a you know i think it's just
a matter of keeping as open mind as
possible and learning all different
aspects of the business while you're
continuing to hone your craft
did the driving job the driving pa job
did that inspire any stories
for scripts no
no it was
it was just um
you know again i was pretty new to la so
i was still like you know again just i
think i was just focused on learning the
terrain at the time
um and i do remember i was working on a
script that i again earlier in my career
one of the mistakes i made was
you know
working working scripts over and over
and over again until it's like look
enough you've written this
you know written
20 different drafts it's all coming out
the same
you know
maybe just need to put this in the
drawer and step away and start
go for something else you know
beating your head against the wall isn't
i i don't obviously is not productive
and i know that um
you know if you have a really great idea
and you love it and you're you're you're
really wedded to it
that's great but sometimes the best
thing you can do for a script that
you're wedded to and you really want to
tell but it's not working is just to
take a step back
and you know put it away and start and
work on something else
you know i know again early in my career
i should have done that with a few
scripts where i'm like i'm just focusing
i'm i'm beating my head against the wall
and and
that was that was about working harder
not smarter at the time and in hindsight
those scripts the best thing those
things those scripts could have used was
was better structure
better
[Music]
better plotting and more and a better
outline and i hadn't really fully
evolved to that place where i was able
to really put
you know to to to write an effective
outline and and really explore the story
that way i think i was just so quick to
go right to jump right into the
screenplay
and
you know it leaves yourself open to a
lot of problems
do you believe characters drive plot yes
oh okay i was gonna say or is it the
other way around it sounds like you
you're very
yes
it's it's imperative they obviously go
hand in hand
but if you don't have
again that intriguing character that
we're going to root for and we care
about
then it just is going to fall apart for
you in your story
that's just again my opinion um
it's interesting because i feel like
there have been you know some movies and
shows made recently and they they go for
this you know anti-hero and
you know again if done you know
we were talking earlier one of my
favorite shows of all time is
californication
and
[Music]
you know you have this anti-hero who is
you he's a rogue he's this this charming
rogue and
he is so self-destructive
and he just you know gets in his own way
all the time but he's got
heart
and he loves his daughter and he's in
love with his estranged girlfriend and
he
you know as as infuriating as he can be
he still keeps us watching because again
we do want to see what he's going to do
next because he's capable of anything
but that we really do care about him not
just because he's hilarious he's funny
and he's a he's you know wizard with
words he's a writer in the series
but he is
but he's just you know there's something
just that we we care about him at the
end of it all through those seven
seasons
and
i feel like you know at times i
lately i've watched some shows and again
it's just my opinions that i feel like
i'm not
you know really on the side of any i'm
not really rooting for anyone and i
think i know the audience wants people
to root for
so
if you don't have that character
developed in a way that we're gonna
you're gonna really have
and again not all stories need
the character needs an arc things do
happen to them but i i feel like
at the end of it all we do want to see
something happen to our character
him or her that changes them
and that we really even if they start at
the place where they're you know a
loathsome character by the end we want
to see them redeemed in some way i think
that's just
our natural inclination you know as
humans you know i think we do we do love
a a good
um
uh
you know in a way not
you know a redemption story but seeing a
character or or character is redeemed
um
so yeah i feel like to just the the most
important thing you can do is you know
again as as i referenced earlier having
those beats those beats are for your
character what are the changes to your
character yes it obviously goes hand in
hand with the plot
but how is your character being changed
by this story and how are they
subsequently changing the story
um
i think every beat really does hinge on
their decisions and
what their what they're choosing to do
in in the story without a doubt
you said earlier you really like to have
the pacing
good and to really push the story along
yeah
has it ever happened where
someone's looked at your script and said
you know what the character's changing
too soon slow it down or vice versa sure
i i i
um
yeah there's definitely that
over the years where i've probably
gotten that note um
[Music]
it has happened i don't recall
on which particular script but it has
happened for sure
and i think it's easy
you know especially in early drafts when
you write an earlier draft and you're
wanting to get it down you know you've
plotted it you have it set you have the
story set you know you have your turns
um
they're hard turns your your you know
people looked at it they're like this is
a really good outline you know time to
go right
um where yeah where it sometimes doesn't
always translate to um you know you may
start doing the character may start
developing a little too soon
i think if that's the case then you kind
of have to go back to the outline and
just
you know
that's why having good structure is
important is going back to the outline
and using it as a reference saying okay
here's where i need that character to
change and etc
um
so yeah i i i do i do think it's um
um
you know it's um it's one of those
things where yeah you there are a lot of
times that again earlier drafts where
you may be
having a character evolve too soon
rather than giving them
her
a um you know letting it gestate a
little bit more
zack what if that outline fails you
what if you outline and then you get to
the screenplay and then it doesn't work
great question um
i i think that it's sort of
you know one of those things where i i
i'll say this it's important i i've
been part of i've been part of many
writers groups over the years and i've
recently been part of another one
for the last couple of years
i feel like if you have a good um
uh
you know if you have a writer's group in
place that that can really help you see
certain things um
fellow writers i should say that
sometimes can
can really help um
and can steer your and and i always feel
like those sessions that i have with
them provide invaluable feedback um i
don't always use all of it
uh but sometimes i walked away with like
that's a great idea um
more to the point about whether an
outline fails and the script doesn't
work
i i fortunately
especially in my later scripts have
always
really worked the outline so that i i
feel like it's pretty
it it's it's pretty solid
but i would say that again going back to
what i referenced earlier if you feel
that you've done the outline you've done
the due diligence on that and you've
done the script and it's not working
i would say go back and re-examine i
think you have to ask yourself why is
this failing like where where is it
landing flat why is it not because
there's a lot of different you know um
uh
areas where you could be coming up short
i'm sure you know
um
but
i think it's it's fair to ask yourself
okay where is this coming up short
going you may not have to throw it all
out but going back to the outline and
seeing okay
maybe re-examining the outline and then
taking it and and reworking the script
again based on that new outline
um or again it just may be one of those
things where the story just isn't
materializing and
you again just maybe need to put that
away for now
and move on to into another idea another
story um
but
you know again
my my advice would be really again to
really
with the outline to really work it well
to get your to have your your your your
key beats down
and to get feedback i think it's really
important to also get feedback from
other writers um and you know
not and people who give you a fair will
give you a fair
you know fair hearing i don't
i don't think you should
why i don't think you should be going to
your mom to get hurt because your mom
and or your dad or
you know aunt sue and uncle johnny are
gonna love it no matter what they're
they're there to champion you and root
you on
i also don't think it's great to go to
somebody who you may know is
you know
you want you who's especially
or unduly harsh i feel like you want
people
who can be fair and with their
constructive criticism and say okay
this is good this is good but this
doesn't work i i think just
you know i knew a few people in college
and again we were just starting out
who would just rip
rip you know his or her fellow students
apart it was just i was like what's
wrong with you you know we're
so i think you have to you have to
encourage that
you know you always have to give
encouragement but i think you could do
it in a fair and critical way but i
don't think you have to rip the person
apart personally so i think it's finding
that good balance and finding a good
group of people whom you trust who will
give you fair
and critical feedback
and you know from there i think you know
then it's about determining the
direction you want to go in do you go
back and rework it or do you just say
you know what i'm going to shell this
for now and move on and i've known
plenty of people who have done both and
um
[Music]
uh again it's yeah so look i i've
started outlines and i've got an amount
of people and i haven't written a word
and this this happened in the last few
years i wrote a number of outlines
and i gave them to people who i was um
i i value their opinion
and they said you know what
this character just isn't likable or
this plot just isn't this this just
isn't working mostly had to do with the
character you know these characters are
just highly unlikable and i don't see
you really
you know making it um uh you know making
this as a film that that anyone's
you know really gonna get um
you know again have any empathy for
anyone that this this was one this is
i'm just this was one script in mind
that that comes to mind um
and another outline where it was just
like
yeah but it's just certain elements just
seem to be too much of a stretch so i
know for me it's like if that outline
isn't working and i'm getting feedback
and it's not coming in and there they're
people who i trust who
are really giving me
i feel
their
a fair assessment
and i was like okay well i think i
maybe it's just better i move on and
maybe later on i'll come back to this or
but this just doesn't seem to be
hitting the the notes that i wanted to
you talked earlier about blake
schneider's save the cat yeah and you
take a lot from his outlining advice
yeah he had um and i said i said earlier
16 beats it's 15 beats he has the the
main the main the 15 beats um
in his story um
and
you know uh
they um you know they they
they pretty much fall in order and take
you through the story
um
but
they definitely are
i think a great
guide and goal posts
to
telling
you know your story and doing an
effective way
um
and um
[Music]
you know they really hit on
again and it goes back to i've said it a
few times working smarter not harder
being able to once you have a clear log
line and you're okay this is the story i
want to tell it's it's concise and it's
just you know it's 30 to 30 to 40 words
um then you start you want to start
breaking it apart and i feel like you
know it starts with a character and from
there you basically fill in that
character's journey
um
you know from um
you know the uh
the first part i know it's always great
as he has opening image
and the opening image is what's the
first thing we say what's the first
thing to remember and i think that's
such a great exercise it's like
how do you want to open the story what
do you want the first thing people see
about your
see about your character and what's it
what kind of impact is it going to have
on them
um you know when it goes all the way
through telling it talking about theme
what's the inciting incident you know uh
the turn the first act turn the midpoint
i will say that i feel like and he did
mention this is in in his book is that
um the midpoint is really the backbone
of the story as he said i believe it's
what you hang everything on
because the midpoint basically is is
that center point of the story
and it does the reversal really of where
that story is gonna turn and go often
you know um a lot of that uh the
reversal of the carrot for the character
really
it's such an imperative uh beat
in the character's journey our hero's
journey
uh you know and then it goes through you
know the third act turn what's the
climax and then finally what's the last
image we see if you think about it and
you really
apply that and you again reference any
number of script but i reference the
movies
you really get a good sense of you know
seeing you know again
we talked about saving private ryan
the film version you see the elderly man
at the end at the beginning and then at
the end and they like to have those
bookends a lot of writers like to have
the the bookends i sometimes have
bookends and it's
you know i think it's it's great to tie
it when one and then the other i know uh
one film that i loved uh most recently
uh that i've seen in years or one of the
films i love most recently uh was 1917
and it began and ended the same way and
it was
you know obviously just breathtaking a
breathtaking uh journey that we went on
and
um
but yeah they you know
again
identifying those beats and having your
character
adhere to it and it doesn't have to be
so rigid i mean again they're guide
posts and their goal posts and
everyone's is different um but i know
for me that
when i do set out it helps me really
determine where my character needs to go
in the story
do you believe anyone can learn to write
a screenplay that will sell well
there are a ton of factors that go into
that um
you know a lot of your viewers have
probably heard over the years that
you know
you don't write
what is fashionable at the moment
because then
after you finished writing a script you
could spend six months a year on it
the market's already moved on
um
so
i
i think
again
it goes back to
you can write a script about anything
and the most important thing is that
your readers and you care about the
character or characters you're writing
about
because if you're just writing it to the
mark and you're just running it to make
you know
for a big spec sale which really don't
happen that man that much anymore
they've kind of gone away
um the marketplace has completely
changed
um
[Music]
you know it's
it's one of those things where um
[Music]
i think you again have to write the
story that you feel compelled to and
again if you're not caring about your
characters
you the writer or not
your readers and your audience or not um
it's a i mean it's a tricky question i
think anyone can write a script that
sells
um those factors and then you have to
have somebody a producer and actor
who are gonna really believe in it um
you know the the
the business has changed so much that
now it seems
you know especially if you're not going
the studio route you have to get
attachments you have to have actors
you know attached
or a director and then the actor comes
in and then you'll attract financing for
it and and financing it all various
levels
um
there have been many terrific
screenwriters in in recent years i've
heard about who have written
tremendous spec scripts terrific specs
that haven't sold
um again because the business has
changed so much
what you're seeing
you know you know you can just
you know anyone can go and see what's at
the cinema or what's not at the cinema
right now but what had been pre-coveted
you know it's it's
sequels prequels comic books adaptations
there's really not a whole lot of
original material maybe some horror and
comedy films that are getting through
but there just really isn't there's a
there's a darth of
you know uh
creative material that's not happening
and
um
[Music]
i i i would just say that you know you
have to write what
is true to you i
i also
would say that
you know don't
you know um don't write about yourself
that old adage don't write about
yourself just try to write a compelling
story uh tell a story not your story
um which i think and again i've known
many writers starting out who wanted to
tell their life story and
with all respect you know unless you're
you know some
you've got some really incredible
rich just
messed up and there are many who do but
um
you know stick to writing about what you
know not about yourself per se i think
um
and you just never know who's going to
be interested anything can happen you
you may
you know you still may send it into an
agency or for looking for representation
they love it and they go out with it um
you could send it to a producer you
could have that actor friend who knows
this well-known actor established
actress and they get it in their hands
and they love it and they want to do it
i have a friend right now who um
uh called up an old connection who's a a
well-known tv actor and he he loved her
script and he wants to do it he's he's
in
um but then it's a matter of getting
other actors attached and getting actors
who are going to get whoever they're
going to bring in and and
be of value especially if you're going
to pre-sell the script in the in the
states
overseas wherever so there's so many
factors that go into it now um
but i think then it just it does always
boil down to the fact of and comes back
to
you know writing a compelling script but
you're just never gonna go to know where
it's going to take you or or how people
are going to react
let's take that same student who came to
you and said zach i want to know how to
write a script that's going to sell how
would you talk to them about working the
craft of writing how would you guide
them i would i would
to speak to them about the um
you know asking them again what is it
what's the what's the idea what's the
what's the pitch
what's the what how are you going to
sell this to me because again
screenwriting is selling you're not only
you're you're not only representing the
product the product that you're writing
but you're representing yourself in a
lot of ways
especially when you get out there and
you start pitching or you go on meetings
um
the the the craft
i mean again i would suggest that they
do read
books like i mean go to red sid field
read blake snyder's books um read
william goldman's books just try to get
every
screenwriting book you can and then read
scripts
read 10 20 scripts
before you actually sit down to start
writing
just getting a sense of of how to go
about it and how again read
read you know 10 oscar-winning
screenplays pretty tarantino read um
alan ball read read
brian helgeland
robert towne
francis port coppola i would say just
read like all great scripts uh herman
mankowitz
i guess herman right who's uh the it was
who wrote a citizen kane
i know there were a few makeovers i
think it was herman yeah that new david
fincher movies out with about him but
um
build you know get those again it goes
back to reference get use those as your
reference
then i think i would say look you have
an idea what's your idea and
what's your log line
and
what is that
what is it about that log line that's
fresh what is it about that log line
that's you know
captivating
what what's the twist what's the irony
and that's in that log line
and then from there just sort of
repeating what i said about earlier
about
then taking it the next steps
you know plotting exploring your
character
wanting to know where they begin where
they end
um that's important you know what is
that where does your character start is
he loathed is he loved
by the end is he loved or is he alot
boiling it down what's his journey what
is he where where's where are you taking
us what do you want to say with that
what's your theme most important that's
a huge part is what are you trying to
say with us
with your with your writing thematically
um
you know is it about you know
the evils of um
of you know is it the evils of war um
maybe that the best there are a lot you
know um is it about a guy choosing
between love and money um
um you know uh
um how far will you go for a corporation
absolutely
absolutely what where where's you know
um or you know again somebody a woman
now or would she go for her for her
children to
you know just watch the undoing on hbo
with nicole kidman and um
you know not to give anything away but
that goes
that definitely touches on that theme
and
um
not uh not to the person that you love
not being really who they
you know um
they claim to be or they are you thought
they were
unraveling them or having the mystery
behind someone
so i think that is something when you
set out to write like what are you
trying to say
um
i had a
a friend of a friend uh boiled it down
to
this when you're writing a story
what's the story about
logogline
what's it also about
what's it really about
and
you know those are those are definitely
i think when you set out like
those are questions that if you answer
them and those are the ones that take
time but i think once you answer them
and you're
you're you're truthful about what it is
and you're and this is where you where
you see it going
again it's like answering these tough
questions early on
opens up the story for you
and um
it's it's but that's what i'm talking
again about working smarter not harder
you can answer you know again those
those 15 beats and these additional
questions early on
it's going to make your plotting process
and your and your writing far easier and
and uh more
uh more enjoyable
and you won't be banging your head
against the law
or worse i like that so
what's it about what's it also about
what's it really what's it really about
wow yeah
and that is um
yeah i remember hearing that probably
about
15 years ago and it definitely helped me
as a young writer i definitely like
opened it up like oh okay
it's um
you know i i think it's what it's
basically saying is you know
once you have the log line that's great
but what is it you're trying to say but
dude what are you really what are you
really trying to do with this
and i think that's something that you
that people should be asked and
sometimes
i think oftentimes people don't know
they don't they can't answer it it's
like all right well
that's okay
but
you better well know it before you sit
down and you you take on the task of of
writing a you know a 90 100 110 page
script
and devoting your emotion and your time
and
taking away you know time from other
things you know
uh to really devote to this because it
is your baby it is your child you want
to know your child inside out right
do the work do the do the uh
you know um do the smart work
i used to work at a company that had
that banner up
above accounting i know and it said work
and i would sometimes transpo i would
maybe that was my own work hard or not
smart oh no wait no that's wrong you
know and i like switch it yeah
yeah it is it's it's true it's um
and again i i for me it's something that
came with with with age and and
you know becoming uh again maturity
for sure and i think initially we're
we're impatient
and look i'm still impatient but with
certain things i become less much more
patient in letting a process play out
it's not always easy but
in the end
you know it's it's it definitely lends
itself to more
um i think more success and more
productivity
if someone came to you and said i want
to learn how to write a script
that will sell yes what would you tell
them
um
well
i would tell them uh
you know ask them what their log line is
and
then i would really
tell them to focus on
you know where that where that where
they plan on taking that character
again i
it's it's tough for me
you know everyone has their own tastes
and everyone you know
sees things in a different in their own
way you know i've
it's funny like i've
put you know back in the day i i
submitted scripts to contests and they
do wonderfully in one contest and you
know make it to the finals
or semi-finals
and then i'd submit that same script to
another contest or to a producer and
they'd be like you'd never hear from
them or it wouldn't go anywhere
it is it is just
it is so dependent on the taste of the
person you're sending it to
i don't think there's any
formula i would say
what does help and is helping nowadays
is
if writers
have
source material um
uh ip intellectual property
they have the rights to
a comic book in our newspaper article as
we were talking about um
a novella um
you know a podcast
podcasts are being made
if you own the ip
so many studios now are and production
companies etc are basing so much of them
as we talked about basing so much of the
material
on
stuff that you know on intellectual
property that's already been written or
or produced or
you know
um or spoken about in the case of audio
in the case of um uh
podcasts
so
that is one way to go if it because then
i think you know if you've got a really
compelling story
and you know you own the rights to it
um
that definitely can get a lot of
people's attention you can say well i
want to write the script
i don't know how most people i don't
know how again i guess it varies from
producer to studio head to what
but that is definitely a way to help
break in um
again if it's if it's a story of
something really compelling
or
multiple people are after it and you
happen to own the rights
that's a nice negotiating bargaining
chip that you have
a new a good way to negotiate yourself
in as a writer
um
[Music]
so yeah that's that's one way to go
i i don't
again um
there's no there's no sure fire way to
to come up i think again if you have a
really great if you're just writing it
as a spec
if you've got a great log line and you
have an intriguing path forward for your
character and you send it to a few
people who are like yeah you're really
onto something here
then you know
by all means see it through but as we
know there are no guarantees in the
business unfortunately
or should the question to the person be
first off before you want to write one
that sells to ask why you want to write
i mean it's not like you're selling time
shares and hey show me how to do it
right and yeah what's the hot market i
mean right and it goes back it goes back
to you know
what you write
you know
what you think you know are you know i
guess you want to write
right now uh the western has come back
and they let's just say and it's it's a
it's a hot market i mean for a while
there it was after um gravity right they
were they were doing all these
you know everyone wanted the studios and
producers uh of all varieties wanted
a great space
film
it's like okay so i'm sure there were a
lot of people who saw gravity got
inspired by our you know becoming
writers
and were like yeah i'm going to write
that next great space film and it very
well may have been a great space film
but guess what the market's moved on
and um
it's like again i think you have to just
you can't write for the market
um in a way you have to let the market
come to you
and that means writing a story that it
goes back to writing a story with
compelling characters who you actually
give a
poop about
and want to see
you know want them you know and you have
others who are invested in them
or in their journey
it's um
that's what i would say and and you you
may you ask a question like well why why
are you writing what's the point are you
in this to make a buck are you in this
too do you actually really enjoy the
craft and the process and all that
and you really have to i'm sure there's
some writers who have just set out to
write a script and they've done it and
they've made money and but
i think the majority of us we really
have to be inspired by
the type of story we want to invest
six months a year
you know if you're writing a novel
two three four five years into
sure so drive did well but if then
you're trying to copy
that style or yeah you always have to be
and i think you always kind of have to
be reinventing
you know yourself i don't say
reinventing yourself as a writer but
in a way yes because you you always have
to
come at it i think from a different
angle an original angle you know look
again coming back to the space story you
know
you know the market may move on but
maybe if you have a unique twist on
you know
you know that space story you know or
on a werewolf story or whatever i think
it's always having that you know um
always looking at you know
in a way
you could have
how do i say it
you can have a same approach to crafting
it but you have to have a fresh take on
constantly a fresh take on on different
stories and how you want to not
necessarily want to tell them but
you know
you know fresh takes and twists on uh on
on
you know your material and and what
you're trying to say
and you know i referenced 1917 it was
like not only was that technically
well done in my opinion i just thought
that
from a sheer filmmaking standpoint but
more importantly from a character
standpoint i mean we were in the we've
got to get we're with this guy trying to
get and it's really not a complicated
story he's trying to get to
you know
get across france to
this guy to tell him that these men are
going to die
and it's life or death
and
his friend dies along the way and man we
are invested these two guys these two
young guys in the middle of this brutal
war
oh my god i am similar saving private
orion i mean
you know you don't have to be a lover of
war films to just be like i was on the
edge of my seat and it was just and sam
mendez is just such a wonderful director
but
wow and again not a an overly
complicated story but just you know just
being invested entirely in the
characters
and then you know getting there in the
end and
it's like he delivers he saves the men
and he has to then then he's got to
deliver this news to the to the
lieutenant whose brother he was with who
died oh man i mean i was i had tears
streaming down my eye you know my my
cheeks it was just it was it was but it
was
it just you talk about a film that just
worked all that stew just worked
brilliantly i like that that's good oh
man it was wonderful a stew yeah that's
good creative stew yeah but for me
personally i hadn't experienced that in
for in a film in a while and i guess i
used to more but i think it shows where
sort of the
where
movie making has gone
studio filmmaking has gone to an extent
what's the best part of the writing
process for you that is a a profoundly
good question
um
i i think when you
find
that synergy
between
your characters in the plot
and again things are starting to roll
and
and it could be in the outline phase too
i've had plenty of experiences with you
know having that breakthrough where
you're like oh right
this is
this is where i need to go um
it's not i don't think it's necessarily
one thing it could be you know you write
it
you write a terrific scene or a great
chapter and
you're just like yeah
then of course you know you could always
go back the next day and think what the
hell did i write
but
that doesn't happen as much i think when
you feel when you feel like you really
pulled out and you really expressed
yourself in a way that or had the
characters express themselves in a way
that
you know resonates with you um
i again i think i think it it's it can
be any it's
it can be anything again from
you know
really thinking up a cool plot point
to really getting that lock that log
line down we were like oh this is you
know i'm on with this and i'm one of
those people who's um
i know uh william broyles jr who is a
terrific screen right he's one of the
best
you know he always i remember reading an
interview with him years ago saying
never be satisfied
and
i agree i i'm not always satisfied i
always want to um
i always think i can do things better
i'm a perfectionist i always want to
continue to mine and if somebody says to
me this we can do that i'm like great
let's let's do it let's mine this let's
let's keep let's dig
um
so
so for me i think when you know um
the the the the
the time where i really feel
where i love with the process that i
love is i think it's just it's the
discovery
discovery of again
your character where they're going um
and it could be you know uh the
character is in
is in trouble and how do we get him or
her out of it
what's a creative way of doing it and
always thinking
you know again i hate the expression
outside the box but thinking outside the
box
coming with a new way
and um a new twist and and how that you
know being inventive
and when that works and it's working on
the page and you or you think it's
working on the page and you're like oh
that's cool and it opens up and it's
that it's those those psychological
breakthroughs in a sense in in regard to
the creative process
so when you start to see that wow these
dots are connecting this is actually
working
it's great it's great it really is it's
um
[Music]
yeah it gives you it gives you uh you
know confidence and
you you just feel it you know it's it
buoys your spirit a little bit like i
said the next day you could go back and
you're like
okay i got through this now
you know that's why i get it's good to
have an outline but even in having the
outline and knowing you know how do you
start up especially in you know writing
you know writing that next scene or
writing the next chapter you're still
staring at a blank page you have an idea
of where you want to go but then it's a
matter of
you know really inventing that and it's
that's something else that's
exhilarating but also daunting at the
same time without a doubt
what's the fastest you've ever written a
full screenplay and did that screenplay
get made fastest
uh i actually i i wrote take back pretty
quickly
the first draft
was probably a couple of weeks
after it outlined it
it was pretty quick um
it took a little while to get made
and it went through subsequent through a
number of drafts but
yeah i probably wrote in about three
weeks
three to four weeks maybe um no not even
four weeks i think it was like three
weeks three weeks yeah i had it i had it
pretty much locked in but again that was
the first draft
and um that's the other thing it's
um uh you know
writing is rewriting is rewriting is
rewriting so
you know
what i always enjoy actually and i
should you know back this up is that
putting the script down is that putting
that primer down is
is fun
but i really enjoy going back and going
back into it
and
reworking it
and reworking it and reworking it
because i think if you've laid down a
good blueprint
and you have a good bare bones
you know what you're basically
transferring from the outline
to that to that script
um
i think that you know going back and
reworking it and making and polishing it
and and really exploring it even more
that's when the real work is done
and that i think is what's most
rewarding for me personally is the
rewriting process
for sure
have you ever fallen in love with a
character not one that you'd written but
another one where you felt that the
person was real you know we were talking
about earlier about salinger and the
letters and this book that i read and
these people related so much to holden
caulfield and they just right they felt
he was so real um sure
did you ever feel that for a character
whether a book
i don't say falling in love but i i've
had some characters that i've been
really taken by um
santiago and the old man in the sea
um
nelson demille who's a contemporary
mystery detective write novels he's sold
very well he wrote the general's
daughter and a few other that have been
made into movies um
he has a character a plum island uh john
corey's character who i adore i think
he's
and demille's
always like
his written uh some some you know he's
john corey is wonderfully entertaining
and funny and witty and and acerbic and
and uh empathetic and i love i love his
cat i love that character
um
off the top of my head um
[Music]
i really recently um i'm like a lot of
other people read where the crawdads
sing
um
and um
the the young little girl who grew up
um
and just um
just sheer empathy for her and her story
um again i don't i didn't fall in love
but just loved
where
what happened and where
she went
um where they took where the writer took
her and and uh
just being so involved and rooting for
her so fiercely i could say that about
jay gatsby
is so mysterious and and i i was always
fascinated more by jay gatsby and i like
i loved catcher in the rye but there was
always something just that allure about
jay gatsby
um
and um
yeah and again i've
you know again my memories coming up
short but um
yeah i don't know i've i've
been invested heavily i don't know that
i've ever completely fell in love with
um
with a character but heavily invested in
rooting for yeah and adoring
characters for sure and i know i gave
you novels i didn't give you necessarily
screenplays but um
you know uh
i think you know one of the one of the
reasons that i am that i am still french
connection is one of my favorite films
is the dynamic between
gene hackman and roy scheider popeye
doyle and sunny um
[Music]
i forgot uh his last name um it was
cloudy
was the nickname popeye and cloudy uh
obviously was their buddy
dynamic
but um also it was again i
you know these were new yorkers like
myself
and they had that attitude and they they
really
i just always took a shine to them i
thought they were they were terrific and
and really loved them and loved how
loved their dynamic and
uh and the movie in general
did you like serpaco yeah another great
one uh pacino
again new york yeah new york and and uh
his uh his intensity in that for sure
and in a lot of his films
how do you write an emotional scene
you know i have a i have a 17 year old
um and we had a
her
you know we were it's a
that's an interesting story in itself
that i won't get too into but
she's um
you know uh we didn't her mom and i
didn't didn't
go about
you know having her the traditional way
it was she was a wonderful surprise
and
i think after especially as she got
older i
we've always been very close we still
are um
and
she's my heartbeat and i think as a
father
it definitely feeds into
um
you know again it's like
you know as a writer
your stories are your your babies your
children um
[Music]
and you feel for them you care for them
and you really and i think i think there
was something about becoming a dad
especially at a young age which i was i
was 26 when i became a dad
that um
really helps you
understand and empathize with
characters and and
tell a story that's compelling i again i
always am able to i feel like
um
[Music]
you know take a
take a step back
and really delve into that you know and
you know we've all dealt we've all dealt
with loss i mean i lost my father at a
fairly young age um
older than a lot of people but still
pretty young
um
and he um
you know he was a a a um
[Music]
a seminal figure in my life
um
and i feel like the you know again like
the relationship that i had with him and
with my daughter and
you know
again having experienced great loss
great
great love
it definitely i think having those
relationships
helps on a lot of levels especially when
you're writing an emotional scene
whatever it may be
um
[Music]
you know it was definitely with take
back
you know the fear of something like that
happened to my daughter
and drove it
at the time she was um when i first
started writing it she was uh eight
and almost nine
and
you know i read about girls as young as
her age throughout the world even the
united states
of
being taken as or
you know being sold off and especially
she got older and we got further along
in the development of the script and
then i became made it was definitely
like oh my god you know she's
this could happen to her and it so
there's definitely some fear that that
drove it
for sure and um
you know i know and it's like uh
how do you
as also sort of like how do you come
back from that how do you rebuild your
life
those were those are definitely
questions that i
you know experienced throughout and as a
father it definitely
had a had a huge impact
i think we can always relate back to our
to our personal experiences and pull
from that i think you have to and not
everyone unfortunately you know and
unfortunately a lot of writers didn't
have that type of
you know tragedy or anything that
happened to him and i certainly you know
i've
you know my dad didn't die in a
terribly tragic way but um
you still feel the same emotion if you
lose somebody you're close to
and if you can infuse that in your
writing and use that
you definitely um again it goes back to
us really caring and giving a crap about
your characters and your story
do you miss your characters when you're
done writing
yeah sometimes
i think if that's a great question i
think if you get really invested
in that story
there's something about it too because
i've gone back to rewrite scripts for
people over the years that i had written
and they wanted to see a draft or
i've been they've been development for a
while and i'll put them aside and go do
something else because you know that
draft is where it is at the moment
but i always look forward to going back
and reworking it it's always good to see
old friends again
seeing uh you know and you know i've
certainly gone back i'm like ugh i'll
cringe what did i write what did i do
um but yeah now i there's definitely
something when you're done with a script
and you're
you know you you put it aside or you're
done in that moment there's
you've kind of got to let it go it gets
easier as you re as you write more and
you can breathe and
you know i've never been one of those
people who's so wrapped up in his world
and and the characters and that worked
for some and i don't wanna but i've
never i've been able to i don't know it
sound bad
some people live and they're in their
characters worlds and that's wonderful i
didn't mean to
you know dilute that experience for them
or or anything um
uh but for me you know it's like
i've i'm i'm invested when i'm writing
and then i'm i am at the end of the day
able to pull myself away of course i
think about
story and where you know when i'm not
there but
i think once i'm done and you know yeah
if you've spent a long time on them and
you're done you do miss it a little bit
you miss that story a little bit
um but then again you always kevin your
back of your head well i may need to go
back in to again make it better refine
it so i'll be back
you know
i'll see you in a little while you know
take some time have a beer and a
cigarette and i'll i'll get you on down
the line you know and um
so yeah
zack you've been generous to send us
your script for take back my pleasure
so we'd love to do a page one analysis
sure so for page one of take back can
you talk about the world you were trying
to create yeah absolutely um
this was basically again we go back to
that opening image
and really wanting to get a grip a grasp
of what this film is about right off the
bat
essentially hitting the audience of the
head so they know what kind of film this
is going to be
and we're in a dark you know we're in a
van we're not sure where we're not sure
with who uh but we can get
you know we we can guess pretty quickly
that it's a young woman um
and she's in a bag and she's tied up and
we're not sure what that is happening
doors are thrown open and she's held out
by a bunch of
seedy looking guys
and we hear voices and
we can pretty much grasp that she's been
taken she's been kidnapped
and
she's going to be used uh
to make these guys money somehow and we
can only guess our worst
our worst nightmare or her worst
nightmare is
really what happens
and that sort of sets up the story and
the data was essentially going back to
what is that opening image and now is
that going to set up the story what does
it mean for genre does it mean for
character what is it that we see right
away and how are we going to get
everyone invested
right off the bat
how many characters are introduced in
this page one scene well again and i
don't want to give i don't want to give
too much away um
[Music]
i won't give too much away um
we do meet uh mickey rourke's character
uh this will be him who comes through
and we do meet the well i'll just leave
it at that i i will say who we it's
three it's three characters
who we meet right from the get-go from
that opening page so you introduce one
of the characters as a vacant looking
man rather than the character name right
and that actually i can say that that
winds up being
mickey rourke's uh the charac mickey
works character whose name is patrick
um winds up being his
doomed brother
i personally
like to reveal as little up front as
possible
um
making it um you know
keeping as much mystery involved
and keeping that reader turning the page
um which are obviously tied together is
so in my in my
um
uh
process
is so imperative
um
giving out just little bits and pieces
here and there
um again i know for some riders it seems
like it's
you know par for the course that's the
way it should be but
you know it's not always the easiest
thing because you don't want to reveal
too much information you want it to you
know just slowly come in in drips
in drips and
keep it going
and um it's you know it's not always
easy to do
it's not always easy to do but um
in this instance yes i wanted to just
leave when i say vacant looking man
you know he'll be coming back later as a
vacant looking man but
then eventually we understand who he is
and where he's identified in the in the
story
so as you said earlier moving the story
forward but again with drips you don't
you just want to hint at this absolutely
keeping the pace and going
i never
and again this is just me i
i am very fastidious about this it's
like you know
scenes should be about two pages
when you're writing each scene should be
two pages so if you're writing they
always say 60 60 scenes if you will
times 220 pages
obviously the length of films have come
down
so
i always try to think about maybe 40
scenes
um
and conflict within those 40 you know um
those 40 scenes i should say earlier um
within the blake snyder thing
there are the 15 beats
that he then expands to 40 beats within
a story
so
for me
it's and i think you could be anywhere
between 30 and 40.
um but you figured those 40 beats are
usually between you know two and three
pages roughly is what you're aiming for
um
so
so yeah it and again i apologize for not
expanding upon that earlier but just
initially getting a sense of the main
beats for the character then expanding
those and that takes you through the
rest of the story for the most part for
me
keeping scenes between
two to three pages
and keeping action lines
never clumping them really keeping it
sparse
letting the story flow letting the
script and you know screenwriting is
very different than prose writing screen
lighting is very
it's punchier
you don't want to write a lot of
surprise description you want to keep it
short you want to keep it compact you
want to get to the point right away
and
that also has that also ties into the
pacing of of your story
um
at least it does for me and i and that
that is that's part of the flow
so again keeping keeping it um
you know keeping it tight keeping it
punchy
lots of white page and just letting it
letting it flow letting it flow
a fluid fluid script you don't want to
get too clumped up
and you want to keep the pages turning
so action line van rolls to a stop
next line side door is thrown open right
blinding light floods in yeah right just
and there there is like a rhythm
exactly there's always a rhythm shadow
shrouded faces appear
rough uncompromising hands grab pull and
drag us out i can i can see it i can
feel like i'm there right yeah and and
you want and and again this is this is
not it it's you may get you may have to
go through seven eight nine drafts
before you get that rhythm down that's
why rewriting is so important first
draft you get it down great good for you
there's going to be a lot more there's
going to be subsequent drafts where
you're really trying to find that pacing
finding that rhythm
finding that that flow to it
that's all part of the process and it's
certainly for me and that's what that's
what took me again i've i wrote many
drafts for this script until i really
got
to that point where i'm like okay
it flowed it flowed how many drafts
over the years easily 25 30
it was a lot in all various stages not
complete page one rewrites but
definitely
different versions writing different
rewriting different scenes can you tell
us about the smash cut i it's funny
because i don't usually don't like
putting in i try to avoid
stage directions as much as possible or
cuts you know cut twos
uh
i'm very limited with those if i'm doing
it it has it's it's there for to have a
profound effect on
you know your match it's almost like a
match cut from um
you know your your character in one
scene's punching and then next scene
that character is punching
or another character's punching so it's
sort of like that smash cut it's it's a
quick cut
to sort of match
to to gel the two scenes together
in a very fast way
normally i don't like putting in um
again stage directions or you know those
inserts
can you tell us about the smash cut
though literally it seems like was it a
happy accident or or deliberate it was
on the bottom
yeah that that very well may have i
think it was um
that was the end of the scene and i
think it was it was probably more of a
happy accent than anything else but it
was great because it ended on that first
page so hopefully they're reading to the
second page
when they see that how long did it take
you to write this first page well it was
again it was it was rewritten um
but something like that
again i mean i
uh
it was i don't have a i don't have a
time frame for that but
you know there are times where i've been
able to write a page like that within
a couple of minutes
other times it takes longer because
again i'm refining it and i'm finding my
way but it it can vary a whole
a whole lot of different you know length
of time for
that particular process
and when you said you did roughly 25
rewrites i realized they weren't all
page one rewrites but what part in
particular did you work most at
that needed the most part oh uh
most mostly her journey
um
changing it for
you know um
because
funny enough mickey rourke's character
was a woman
really but we got mickey and i was like
they said can you make this a man i said
sure why not you know mickey rourke why
not sure that definitely changed that
dynamic a little bit
but
i think it had more to do with her
journey and her character and then at
other times making the plot making it
fresher updating it
i would say at certain points some of
the action
you know
i think for the most part um
you know it's zara now but in the script
it's sarah the zara character uh or
sarah sorry i did change her along the
way and there was definitely certain
changes but she always was kind of like
again i i i stuck you know it was this
woman who
committed this act of heroism
she was trying to escape her past
had the spotlight turned back on her and
you know all the all the bugs came out
under the light to
make her life a living hell and she had
to fight back
and take her life back
so that was kind of always that was
pretty much always there
um
so but there were always tweaks that i
made too again her story and her
background and
just to make it more compelling
and her more compelling
is this first page still the opening of
the movie
i don't know
i don't i don't think it is okay
judging from the trailer too i'm not
sure i don't think it is okay yeah well
i don't want to say anything sadly okay
jeopardize it because i really like that
opening
but again can't be wedded to our work
yeah
you get paid and it's like
looking back at it now with the first
page take back were there any mistakes
anything you feel like you could have
done better or you happy
with
exactly how it flows
i do like the flow
i am
i'm never gonna say i'm satisfied but
i'm happy with where it's at at the
moment
somebody came around and said hey we
could do this i'd be like great
i like that idea let's do it
amenable to it
i think filmmaking is so much about
collaboration
and hearing other people out kind of
like a life
which we've kind of eschewed lately
i feel that
you should always be willing to hear
what people have to say even if you
don't like the idea hear them out
don't dismiss it outright if it's the
most inane
effing idea you okay
but
somebody may just as an aside say yeah
but you might think about um you know
giving her um you know a little charm
blaze that you can bring back later or
something like that
as a symbol bad example but
think about it that's a really good idea
work that in or some way symbolize that
symbol term
ties back to the theme
um
[Music]
so
where it's at now i
i think it accomplishes what it needs to
i think it sets up the sets up the film
with some mystery
we get a sense of danger we get a sense
of establishing what genre does we get a
nice opening image
um
yeah but um
and i will backtrack that
getting to that opening image the actual
writing of it didn't take long but i
think working around some scenes that
had been there prior and making it
that took some re-shifting and some
rewriting the actual scene itself to
write wasn't too didn't take too long
but there was definitely parts of drafts
that were different that had different
opening images and i think
for me it was about
streamlining it and making it as concise
and simple and quick as possible again
that's how i work i want to know
you know
delving into it as quickly as possible
and getting
to the story you know
and getting to our our characters
and and and getting to those those main
beats as fast and concisely as possible
is so important did you cut down a lot
of dialogue and of the action lines um
it's not too much there were some
there were some
um
yeah probably uh maybe you know in that
instance maybe a quarter a half a page
yeah because they didn't really need to
be much that needed to be said
that's what i that was in my intention
again i think you do more
by showing more and saying less
take back coming out
in 2020 2021 i'm um i don't quote me it
should be coming out in between april
and june we're hoping it's some i'd just
say the spring at some point in the
spring maybe
mid to late spring
right and it was shot during covid it
was shot during kovid it was one of the
few movies made during covet it was shot
in la and out in the palm springs area
yes right and it stars stars mickey
rourke uh michael jai white uh gillian
white james russo
and a handful of other
actors and actresses who you've
definitely seen at a theater near you or
on television so yeah yeah it was a
really good cast really
um they did a terrific job with the
casting without a doubt
and i know it it took a little bit to
get made and were
yeah it was it was it was definitely a
process um we had a
you know again um
i had uh
met uh through um
i had sent the script to a producer
friend of mine and he had gotten it to
the christian sesma who's the director
and my captain who's a producer um
both have worked extensively in the
business mike is actually as an actor he
was in uh the green book and number of
other films
uh christians worked on a number he
christian actually has just had a film
come out early this year with val kilmer
called paydirt
and he's
directed a number of other films um
[Music]
and
yeah so
we went to them and you know they they
signed on pretty quickly
and then we were able to get mickey work
attached
and
we unfortunately
had an investor drop out
and
we needed to fill that so we went to
a financier fairly big finance here in
town
who
stepped in and
we unfortunately weren't able to
get it done with him
so we we signed on and then it just it
just didn't happen and then we the
rights reverted back to me
and after that we were able to find a
financier pretty quickly
uh plug the the budget shortfall that we
had had from uh the initial investor
backing out
and
we got it made and
it's it'll be out soon
excellent okay and we'll have a trailer
of course in the link below yeah
absolutely that is the official
trailer now we're gonna go to page two
and we see our protagonist and she's
sparring and she's throwing a a punch
why did you decide this was the best way
to introduce the protagonist
sure
um well i wanted to have a
part of the put an impact
on how we see her
right away um
you know the next the next scene is uh
of her
as an attorney she's a small town
attorney
i wanted to set up the fact that she had
a bond her husband is the one she's
sparring with in the scene we don't know
until the end of the scene that it's him
uh we think she's just you know doing a
sparring session with someone but it's
her husband who's taught her all this
she's proficient she's athletic and
she's an accomplished lawyer
in this small town
um for me those were the priorities set
her up as well as a relationship with
her husband
um
and we did it without a lot of
dialogue um more of the action i also
wanted to establishers martial arts
involved in the story
and
again this is going to be a thriller
with action elements
so for me and i think as a writer
putting as much of that in there without
saying much i think is really important
i had mentioned earlier i think
sometimes people especially young
writers start out and they become just
enamored of dialogue
and
the less
you can say to move your story forward
the better
dialogue should be there to service
the story
to move the plot forward to move your
character forward
not just to
you know
you know i i think people just will
throw an extraneous dialogue just
because they love the sound of it and it
does nothing for the story
except slow the pacing as we've been
alluding to
and
um
for me and that in those scenes
it was like just
get to the point without saying a whole
lot in expressing it in images because
movies are images and i i once a
professor of mine actually at nyu said
you know if you can watch a whole film
with a sound off
and you know at the end understand then
that movie's been successful you don't
have to listen to what they're saying
and you just follow the images
that's pretty darn good if you can say
it without you know
tarantino film might be difficult to
watch that way but at the same time
you you'd be surprised even though he is
such a master dialogue writer and he's
so terrific with that um
he can still put together a heck of a
story
on pages eight through 11 we have our
next piece of action which serves as the
inciting incident i believe okay can you
talk about the moment in the screenplay
uh whether it was structured or not yeah
that was definitely structured because
that's where she
um
[Music]
goes in and
has that
you know uh becomes the hero and exposes
herself so that was definitely always
going to be
the inciting incident
for sure
is it okay to talk about
what happens here yeah there's not too
many spoilers okay not at all so she's
she's it shows too that that
her her
strength training and and martial arts
and and the boxing and all that becomes
a major piece in this it comes in handy
yes big time and she again she commits
that act of heroism that then exposes
her to
the national media and
she becomes a story
right and then you see that her phone
she starts being text by you know
family journalists all these different
things exactly
and what seems like sort of an exciting
good thing
is quickly about to turn
yes
exactly again she's exposed she's
exposed to uh the wrong people as it
were yeah
seems like there's a lot more dialogue
in this section yeah okay
yeah it was it was basically she's um
trying to talk this guy down and and
say look you know you know speaking to
the
speaking to the checkout counter girl
um
but and then ultimately him wanting that
pin that was so important to her
and that her husband had given her which
is symbolic which is a symbol throughout
the rest of the film
um
that definitely drove most of the
dialogue there and became the source of
conflict for her
taking the guy down because he wanted
that pin and she wasn't going to give it
up
and she was able to take him out i think
if she had just said you know
i don't
want any trouble just walk
she would have let him walked but
because he
decided to instigate
she had the wherewithal and the training
to
to do that and put him out
in a very heroic way
so yeah
and the pin sorry that's not a mcguffin
is it no it's okay so i was thinking of
a macguffin it would be some type of a
symbol
or so correct me how would that be what
would what would that be called that pin
because it interplays into the right i
would just say it's symbolic of you know
the relationship and the dynamic that
she's created with her with her husband
because it's symbol is an asian symbol
for best friend okay and it's and he
gave it to her and it's emblematic of
their relationship and
their
you know it comes to play as the story
goes on that she still has it and in the
end
when
you know again not to give too much away
but when you do have that she does have
that final battle
it's and again this is in the script
um that it's something that she has to
you know she
you know
gained strength from
in the knowledge that you know again
she's wearing this on her heart and it's
again emblematic of her husband's
support and her life her new life
and how the old one is coming back and
that contrast and she has to be strong
and stay strong
and hold on to the new life and not let
the old
obviously nightmarish one come back for
her
and not only that but this stranger who
has held up the liquor store the
convenience store
he wants that yes and that's he wants to
take it from a symbol too of yeah
exactly right right exactly
yes so in many ways it's symbolic of
this is her new life and then an evil
force is trying to come and take it
absolutely interesting in a place
throughout it plays throughout um
and again it was um
[Music]
you know uh
it's definitely one of those things
where
you know
there there are there are a lot of
people that force that
force-feed symbols in sometimes in
movies
but i think it can definitely be done in
a way that's um subtle
and still have greater meaning
and uh to the rest of the story
throughout and carry it throughout
are they dramatically
okay and are there overt symbols and
then covert symbols like i think they
said with like the artist
they they showed like a descending
stairs when it was the economy was bad
sure and that some viewers i mean i
actually wasn't totally aware of that
yeah i think some of those are choices
by the director i think sometimes
in a script we do
you know we will put stuff in you know a
symbol in of of some kind
um
we hope to make you know something
tangible
um but oftentimes i think the choices
that directors make or um you know on
their set
when they're making the movie it becomes
they they kind of come up with their own
you know they find a way
to to play it up
you know whatever it may be sometimes
it's in the script
but other times yeah i think they the
way it's shot
and
you know
the way the set's designed
as we said in film school the mison sen
sort of
lends itself to creating those
opportunities
for some for symbolism in a film
how many drafts of the script did you do
before you had other people start
reading it at that point maybe a dozen
i was yeah i was rewriting it a bit
because sometimes i would come back to
it somebody would be interested um well
i shouldn't say initially my manager got
it out to people so
i mean early i would say maybe not that
many when somebody the first person read
it you know whatever it was seven eight
years ago um
so
yeah and maybe uh i shouldn't say that
maybe it was maybe three or four drafts
i i went back and rewrote it a couple of
times before i actually started sending
it out
for sure and again it was a different
time you know there weren't
the studios i think were still putting
those movies out and there were still
producers who were willing to put up and
financiers who were willing to put up
their own money
you know and they didn't need
necessarily need stars attached they
would you know work with you develop it
with you and i think
became more prevalent in recent years
where they started
attaching actors and and
directors and trying to pre-sell the
film uh especially in the independent
world before they
would um
before uh
they would commit to
going into production
what were the first notes you were given
on the screenplay
my manager
early on i think
um i i don't recall what they were
i think he liked my first couple because
i probably wrote a draft and rewrote it
and then got it to him
overall i think it was pretty positive
um this was sort of what he had in mind
um
but i don't remember exactly
what the detail i'd have to go back and
uh look for that email i'm sure i saved
it um but yeah it was it was it was uh
my my manager um
is a wonderful guy still is he's one of
my my dear became one of my dear friends
um
[Music]
he was great because he always saw a big
picture he was never
a
micro note giver he was more of a macro
note giver
and sometimes he'd sent he gave me
feedback and i would be like what's he
saying
and then it would hit me later that day
or the next day i'm like okay
because it would be vague
but i'd think about it
and then it would be vague anymore he
had that gift
and i've always been what i've given my
friends i'm i'm a macro note giver i try
to be as concise as possible as positive
as possible
i don't like to burden people with too
many notes i find big picture
i have big picture thoughts
try to go for maybe two or three
again
sometimes they're good they might be
very positive notes like keep doing this
sometimes okay you have to
pick up the pacing here um
but i don't i don't get into the
minutiae of
you know
note giving i'm pretty broad speaking
and
[Music]
it depends some people prefer that other
people don't i know sometimes for me
i would
like people to be more specific
because it would help
but
you know everyone has their own way of
of giving notes so
um
i just you know i just i just roll with
it as best as i can and
you know try to um
[Music]
again try to uh be as helpful and
inspiring as i can with my notes to
people and
encouraging i should say not inspiring
but encouraging
can you give me an example of micro
notes
yeah
micro note giving is um
a bad example
why is his name bob and not jim
bad example
um i just i just feel like very much in
the minutia um
maybe
um
starting to sort of
you know
at times it's helpful but
rewrite dialogue in a way that i don't
think is
really maybe the
the prime
problem in that script
where it's like okay
we have a script
we don't care about the main character
at this point it's it's page 10.
um
they're
they're being overly descriptive
they're um
they have a voice over that's basically
explaining everything that's going on
um
[Music]
and um
you know and it's slow
and the pacing is off
but we're talking about this one stretch
of dialogue or you know
again maybe not the best example but
it's stuff like that where i feel like
you know
i i i'm always like
okay what do i really like about this
script always start off with that
but then say okay but i feel like you
know you have a and i'll focus on
certain parts of the script like you
know
act three doesn't have a hard enough
turn
where where have they where has he
where is he or she at the end of the
story or at the end of the second act
when
they have to make that they have that
cathartic moment that then is going to
turn them into the third act like
really what is that why they started out
here at the beginning of the script
they're now at their lowest ebb they're
in the the dark knight of their soul and
their
what is going to bring them out of that
they're at their lowest point what is it
that that's going to turn them that's
made it all up into this point that's
going to make them make that turn that
hard turn into the third act in order to
finish their story and and win in the
win in the end
um
it's stuff like that you know which i
think i again and i think a lot of
people focus on but i think sometimes
you know macro notes we start getting
again into the into the real minutia
you know sometimes people like that
sometimes it helps but unless you're you
know unless you've
you know gotten you've been paid to
write and you're and you're getting uh
you know
a thousand note you know a thousand
notes from the studio executive or
producer with every little you know line
iteming every every part of it you know
it's
you know it's um
i don't know i don't know how always how
helpful it is but
yeah but that's just me
how do you protect your script before
sending it out wga
register it
copywriting isn't the worst idea either
but i think most
uh most wga um you know get it
registered the wga it's like 20 bucks
you can do it online it takes like
five minutes if that
um
[Music]
and your cover and i think it covers
your for for up to five years
renew it after that um
but uh yeah that's and copyrighting
to a degree but i think in the business
as long as you have a wga i know there
there have been a lot of instances of
people
having their work stolen etc and and
it's um i should say a lot but there are
instances of it um
i think people are more
um
i don't know
again i've heard of it happening
but i think it happens
less than
maybe
people think that stealing material i
you know you guys may have heard of
more so but i've always known that you
know there again there are some
instances like i know the coming to
america script was like a big deal
that that somebody claimed that eddie
murray murphy stole that
you know stole their idea and it was a
whole
lawsuit uh dodgeball i believe was
another one
so yeah um
again i i would say to cover but to
cover yourself and your story yeah wga
or just
wga west or east
they have registration you go in there
and that definitely covers you up too it
gives you a little uh or gives you a lot
of comfort knowing that you're there
that you're
have your script registered
not mailing it to yourself
poor man's copyright that's a that's a
good question i mean potentially but you
could do that but i would also say you
know and i think also with you know
having electronic documentation if you
do send it out
can't hurt uh correspondent i don't know
people write many letters anymore but
having physical correspondence um
but i i i think the wga is definitely
the the easiest and the smartest way to
go
are you careful with who you share your
ideas with
i am
uh
you know family members ask i will tell
them friends who i i've known for a
while
sometimes i'll be out and will um
you know whenever i'm among people who
you know especially my i'm in the
writers group i share
and i've shared it with some other folks
i don't get to
and i'm gonna i'm gonna knock wood here
i don't get to i don't get too worried
about it um
again because i know that i have my
script registered and and all that and
um
you know i have a good lawyer
i have a really good lawyer
so
they can try
but
he's a savage so
and he's he's pretty well known so
you try
i don't think it would be a good idea
in general what are the best ways to
have an uncredited writer find script
buyers
well there are
i know that uh
[Music]
the contests have always been a way to
get your work out there
um
i think there are a handful of of
contests like the nichols fellowship
um or nickel pickle fellowship um
a few other contests that are there i
would you know i think any writers
starting off you should go you can
google it best screenwriting contest
and see for yourself
and you know that's one way to do it i
mean the fees you know the fees it's
usually anywhere between
early entry fees or anywhere between 40
and 60 bucks i don't think they've
fluctuated much in
in the last 15 20 years
that's one way to go um i will say with
the contests you gotta win
i think if you win it opens doors i
think even if you make it in the finals
i placed in a lot of contests uh in in
semifinals quarterfinals finalists even
um in nickel right uh i was a
semi-finalist in nickel years back um
with the pirate hunter script believe it
or not which was a shock i just sort of
submitted it for poops and giggles and
went in
and uh it made it uh
and made it all the way to semifinals i
had that was actually a film a script
that i had co-written uh with an old
friend of mine and um
i was amazed because i know the nickel
always focused seemed to focus more on
you know drama maybe some comedy some
thriller but this was a straight
straight
action movie
um so i was impressed that it uh it got
as far as it did
um
and it got me my first manager who is
still my
dear friend
so it definitely opened some doors it
got me some meetings
um
but i feel like you still need to come
away with the top prize in that um maybe
a runner-up
um
there's also uh for writers inc tip
which is um a website that is devoted to
you know you put your logo you can
upload your log line
synopsis you can put a treatment and a
script um and or i think it's treatment
and or a script up there
and that definitely
there there are a lot of production
companies who are on there there's i
think they have something like 15 000
members
and that you can subscribe they send
your log line out and you'll have people
come and they can contact you i used to
have some stuff listed on there i had
somebody contact me never really
materialized
but there are people that are looking
that's one way to reach reach other
folks
other than that um you know i know it's
time of covid
networking is definitely a good way to
go uh it really is all about who you
know um
and
you know that's that's
that's a great way and and working
working in an agency working in a in a
um a production company um
those those are definitely
ways of you
you can
get your work to somebody potentially
within those agencies companies etc that
might be able to open some doors for you
working working on shows working on
a tv show working on a film
and continuing to work on
various productions again you accrue a
lot of people they know it's what
happened with me when i started off uh
knowing going from one to the next to
the next and sort of broadening your
your scope of contacts um
you know it's a funny story
i remember this is before i even thought
about it being a tv writer
um
i was on i had just left law and order
um the law and order show after two
years and i
had given my script to
a writer there
and
she got in touch with me a couple months
later she said you know i read your
script it's really good she said have
you considered tv writing
and at the time tv writing i just wanted
to write movies
and foolishly and this is something that
i say to anyone watching
if you have one of the top tv writers on
law order or one of the tv writers in
the business and again this was before
the advent of like you know tv was
starting to come to the fore and and you
were starting to get into the golden age
but this was like probably a few years
before that
and i was just so focused on being film
writer
but this woman said to me you know um
and i i given her the script because i
admired and respected her immensely and
her talent
when she was one of the top writers
there i said she wrote she she called me
she said um
[Music]
this is really good and have you
considered writing tv and i said i
haven't
and she said well i would
and i didn't really heed that call until
later and i did write some pilots and i
actually did get some meetings with
folks and tv and some at some of the
networks with some of the pilots i had
written
but i wish i had heeded that call
earlier and some of your viewers are
probably looking at this and saying what
a schmuck and you yours are right what a
schmuck if you have that opportunity you
you hear those voices you they're it's
all signs
read the signposts if somebody says hey
you know what you may want to consider
writing this or
working on that or
you know
take it because there are not a lot of
opportunities in the in the film
business and if you if you're there to
heed the call it could lead to some
really
uh potentially wonderful things
that's a great story yeah i mean maybe
just wasn't right for you at that time i
wouldn't i was young and dumb and etc
that's all i'll say i had certain things
that yeah if i think back but yeah she
was a she was a i mean for her for her
because i was gone from the from the the
the um
the show at that time i was long gone
she did not have to call me
she did not have to call me up
and you know you know when i left i said
to her like i always i told her i said i
really appreciated
you know you really
were inspiring to work for you were
always really cool and and
and
and i admired who you were who you are
so i don't know if that did it but she
did get back to me she didn't have to
and she did and she was just very
complimentary and i just wish in
hindsight you know maybe i had but like
you said i was in a different place than
i think i was 25
yeah you know so
and you're thick at that and that's what
i'm saying like it there takes some
maturation
also do so many things are being
presented to you at that age
and and so i think there's this weird
skew that you think it's always going to
be yes that way especially
you do and and you do you just think no
i won't you know i get that next
opportunity in three months right you
know something else right and and you
you look you know the one thing i'll say
is that nobody ever said to me
and i'll still knock wood nobody ever
said to me stop writing you just don't
do it it's you need to find a new career
path nobody ever said that to me
and
i mean i guess we wouldn't really say
that to anybody but if somebody's really
being blunt sometimes they would like
you just don't have it you know and i'm
not saying i'm
i have it i'm just saying that
in my professional experience nobody
ever said just stop
this isn't for you
sure and sometimes if someone says it
doesn't even mean it's that somebody's
trying to sabotage someone so you just
never know what their opinion right what
their
agenda is
and a funny and real funny story so that
script that went to the semifinals in
nickel
three months earlier we had somebody
submitted to this film production
company which is no longer around and
they made a couple of comedies that
weren't very good but their director of
development it's though it is the
meanest response i ever received and i
was my writing partner and i at the time
we received it
this
development exec said
it's not
such-and-such material
it's not this company's material i
remember thinking and you made that film
and you're and i was
i was so one we went and i'll tell you
i admire my restraint
um
because after we made it all the way to
the semifinals it was like
i still had a little bit of acid in my
mouth about that i just want to write oh
really well it's nickel material but i
didn't do that i'm not like that i just
but i was like wow
that was definitely
you know just
i don't know if she meant you know this
isn't for us you know but to just you
know to go out of their way and say this
is not
this doesn't rise to our level
i was like wow okay
yeah you just wanted to put you just
wanted to put us down all right
all right well they're non-existent
anymore so
we all got the last laugh because
somebody went to see their movies i
guess
but it was
it was a really mean mean-spirited thing
to say i thought i would never ever say
anything like that to anybody it's a
very conceited thing
yeah i almost feel like it's a hazing
and that's the only way i can think of
it is like you've got to have a bunch of
those to just keep you absolutely i'm
going to keep getting you know because
absolutely yeah it's it's
they do happen they do what do you think
it was about take back that excited
producers and financiers well it
definitely helped to have mickey
attached
um
i also think that
in the marketplace now i think thrillers
like that
you know thriller horror films that have
a decent hook to them that can maybe you
get a good attachment uh cast wise and
that can be made fairly cheap um
will definitely help your cause um
i you know
you know you want to write something an
obviously minimal location i mean i
always think a saw
which is just brilliant because it
actually was a
short film
which they then expand into a feature
but it was really obviously took place
mostly in one location
uh take back had multiple locations but
it's a smaller indie action film
that you know was able to be confined to
the small town um
so
i think that definitely helped it um
and um
but you know
a film that's got like a
you know i i would say a budget of
between half a million and maybe one and
a half million two million
um
you know not a lot of locations and and
still
you know is a solid you got a solid 85
90 page script to work from
and uh again you're not there's not a
huge lot of of of location changes
um
and not a huge cast
you know i think people are and and
again you get a good attachment could be
anybody um who will bring money into
these foreign territories and pre-sell
the film you're going to be in good
shape easier said than done yes
but
definitely it's it's not impossible
and i will say real quick i think
based on what we were taught you made an
excellent point before when we were
talking off-camera about
the the you have these sort of the the
huge studio budget films that are like
300 million
and then you have these smaller
budgets like take back etc
that are going you know anywhere between
half a million to low seven figures
there's really not a lot in between
that's happening
you know
unless maybe you're at netflix or amazon
but the studios are generally you know
they're they're
you know they're trying to hit it out of
the park every time
within these huge budgets and the
smaller films are you know being made in
the way take back is with foreign
financiers um it's not all foreign
financiers there was a mix but um
[Music]
definitely different um
uh you know conglomeration of different
producers and
um uh
financiers and production companies
and then you know but the the in between
the 30 40 50 60 million dollar films
they're not really being made as much
unless again there's there's a major
actor attached and they are doing it
maybe independently of the studio um but
you know i'm sure they exist but
it's like we talked about before it
seems like there is this
big gap between what's the reality and
of what's happening now
with as far as movies being made
how did you get mickey work attached so
early
that was all mike hatton the producer
he uh
he hadn't i i believe
he
had
knew
mickey's
agent or manager
and was able to get it to him
that way
i believe or he had a connection somehow
and was able to get mickey the script
and mickey signed on pretty quickly
he signed on very quickly james russo
had already been
attached so
and james and mickey i believe knew each
other too that may have helped a little
bit but i think
you know
mickey was mickey was the big get and
that was again done through
mike's mutual uh a mutual acquaintance
of my cats
why didn't mickey work leave the project
because we paid him a lot of money
well i know that the project was sort of
in flux it was for a while okay we had
him there um
and uh
he to to his credit he's he stayed he
you know
he was staying part he wanted to be
involved
um
you know the his character is also a uh
takes care of he runs an animal saying a
no kill dog shelter
in the film that's his character what
his character does
and mickey as we know is a big uh he's i
think a peta spokes person
so
you know
it would it had a lot of elements that i
think he
appreciated
and that kept him there for a bet
and the fact that we paid him a lot of
effing money
to be in it
that definitely helped
that definitely helped
what kind of conversations did you have
with mickey rourke about the script and
his character
i didn't have any conversations with him
um
[Music]
i
the the script
so
this was an interesting one because
there was no
i i was paid
but i wasn't but it wasn't as a spec and
it was not a work for hire
i was paid as a portion of the budget
um
so
basically
once my
i turned in my pre-production draft
they
the director christian and the actors
kind of took it from there
i really didn't have a lot of
um
i'm didn't have any involvement in the
pre-production
uh planning or
you know
discussion um
my role was fulfilled is i fulfilled my
role as a writer and
[Music]
and that was and that was how it went um
so they made changes
um to the script and um
and again it was there
it was their script to make changes too
because i had been compensated and
um and i think there it'll turn out well
you know with what they what they come
up with i'm i'm optimistic
um but it was um but i never
i i met uh gillian and michael j white
on set i i had known i had met james
rousseau a few years earlier when we
were sort of getting in the
you know we were in the infant stages of
getting the film up and going um but i
uh unfortunately did not meet mickey or
speak to him he had more direct
conversation with uh
christian the director and mike the
producer
how did you get the producer mike hatton
on board so
the gentleman who
was
the lead producer initially
we were he was in the he was in the
market for finding a director he found
christian
christian worked with mike hatton
and
they were producing partners mike was
still acting he was at that point i mean
he was in the green book
and he still he's still in a bunch of
films prior and after green book
um
but mike you know to mike and christian
really took to the material
and because mike was christian's
producing partner
um
they came and we're both involved in the
uh
um
in the process from then on and and mike
you know i can't say enough good things
about him like
his energy you know um
his support and um
you know again enthusiasm and chris's
too uh but mike's mike's like the
energizer bunny he's he he's go go go
and and i really i can appreciate that
about him he's a hustler
and
you need somebody like that i think
especially navigating in in a more in
the indie world even even in a studio
film world you know to have to have a
guy like that on your side who's
hustling is trying to get things done
and doing 300 things at once and getting
them done and getting them done well
efficiently you know i hope to make more
films with with mike down the line i
really do
i really do
but we'll see
you know
he's he's he's working on uh you know
three things at once literally he's he
they just finished uh
um two more films since take back
and um with with really good casts um
so they just he's always got something
going on as does chris
where were you emotionally and what
happened when you heard that the film
may or may not happen
oh it was definitely over the years as a
roller coaster i've had some of those
other some other experiences like that
where films were you know on the verge
i it was it was it was always teetering
on that line of will it or won't it for
a while
and um
i think i became so
and again it wasn't
it really just had to do with the lining
up the money
it wasn't that i i was i didn't think
that you know micah chris was
enthusiastic i just thought it just came
down to dollars and cents
and
you know uh so but i became very just um
sort of uh immune to the
the roller coaster of emotions and just
sort of accepted everything as it was
and
just you know was optimistic that it
eventually would happen it was just a
matter of timing like everything else
so something that you
practiced early on or you learn to
develop i just it's comes with age
and maturation
and and my martial arts training
you know
again i'm i'm an impatient person by
nature
but i've definitely tempered it learn to
temper it over the years and just keep
everything in perspective and there's
just so many things that are out of your
control
i tell that to my wife all the time it
was like
with you know with any aspect of life
um
and filmmaking obviously is no different
you just it requires such a tremendous
amount of patience look i have a film
another film now
that i've been sitting on for four years
which i think is a
you know very timely concept
with everything we're going through it
was timely four years ago
um
but
trying to get everybody in sync
with everyone's schedule and i don't
blame anyone everyone's got their own
thing they're doing but
it it definitely gets to the point and
i'm still guilty of being of being like
you know what in the effort we doing
what's going on here
um
it can be very it can be very just
you you really have to learn to
you know i would say you know if it's if
it's a year
that's one thing but we're you know when
you go on three four years and you're
still waiting it's like okay
you start to get a little like
you start to get
you know a little uh wary about where
everything is and
you know just hope that
again your number's called but
again so many things are out of your
control
and again that was a teacher at nyu that
said if you stick with it eventually
that was my manager your manager okay if
you if you keep if you keep at it you
know eventually your number comes up i
learned that about i learned that about
my wife you know i i was single for many
years um
[Music]
and
i would get frustrated that i was like
you know i just like to meet a nice girl
um
and uh somebody who i i really felt that
connection with and it took a long time
but
you know eventually my number got called
and we've been you know actually we just
uh we've been together four years of as
of yesterday and oh great we met four
years ago yesterday and then uh we've
been married for
close to two years congratulations you
know thank you very much um but
it it it just
i think it i think it's just um
look some people have it sooner other
people it happens a little bit later
and you just i think if you can just
stay optimistic and stay focused and and
keep moving forward and not get
discouraged and it's so hard to get
discouraged it's so hard
um
but
i really believe that if it's you're
truly passionate about it
and at the same time you have you have
that talent and you have a story
multiple great stories to tell but just
take one just takes one
it'll it'll eventually it will
eventually
get you there
i do believe that i'm living proof of
that
but again it's it's not getting
discouraged so many people
actors writers directors everyone comes
to how hollywood is is
is is
meant to discourage you
it's here to discourage you it's it's
the you know development development
people are are paid to say no
they're paid to say no to
to writers
so
you know and it's so easy to just get
discouraged and turned off by that and
we all have dealt with it
but i will say that
you know
if if if you
stick
to your guns you keep honing your craft
you
stay encouraged not discouraged
and you keep marching forward
sorry for for you know the cliches but
it's true
um and you have and you do have a talent
for it
even a modicum of talent if you have it
and you keep nurturing it
you know
and you and again eventually
you know i do i do think i i think it
was um i do think it was aaron sorkin i
believe who said um
you know good material eventually finds
its way
i believe it was him
yeah it sounds like i watched the master
class with him it was excellent i feel
like you might have said that as well
and in a sense not not to cheapen dating
with with the film industry but there's
some similarities in that in la the
dating world is so much about oh how do
they look on paper absolutely where'd
they go to school what are they how do
they look at first what's this oh yeah
what are some of them sometimes people
don't even care about that they just
want to know what do they do for a
living yeah absolutely and so
that equates the same way in the film
industry who's attached what what is
this and it's like the same now i need
something bigger i need this i need
better but then that one special thing
i.e or the special person
you can somehow find that but it takes a
long time i think yeah
it it sometimes can sometimes it's quick
sometimes it's
you know it doesn't take as long
sometimes it takes longer
um
and again you know i'm not saying look i
mean people may
read the read take back or watch tape
back eventually be like you know what
but
you know
we've all seen those movies we're like
what were they thinking you know how did
this thing get made i'm guilty of saying
that
i am
but
i still think that there has to be a
couple of things the the the
the script has to be somewhat decent all
right it has to be legible it has to
have some kind of emotion tied into it
and again you don't know how how it
could just affect and somebody reacts
luckily you know christian mike
both really liked the script they dug it
and they were like okay we're let's
let's get rocking on this the producer
who took it to them
was the same way like
they took to it and again i had
a number of people who are lined up who
did really like the script and and were
high on it so that was i had that going
for me um
but sometimes look it it may again bring
it back to the french connection i think
that went to 25 different places before
somebody said yes really yeah
i believe don't quote me but i believe
it went to every studio in town
production companies it went all around
and there's a handful of other
screenplays that went around you know it
it was
and it wasn't like you know the the
a bidding war for them
and you know you saw and you saw what
what what amazing movies came out of
that and again i'm not saying ours is
going to be on that level but
all it takes is one person to say yes
20 people may say no
25 in the case of french connection say
24 said no and then
um i believe it was um
[Music]
um
oh
zanac i believe was oh okay dick zanac
said yes
when he was running things over there he
was young he was the wonderkind
and his father daryl had run fox and he
said yes
it's it's um
that's it and if you're and
i was fortunate that that happened
and i hope it happens again
i believe you said you've been writing
scripts ever since you were at nyu yeah
how many years did you go even though
20. okay
i optioned i did option a number of
scripts along the way
um
and
iowa again i had
i was fortunate that some of my scripts
served as good samples to get me into
meetings with a number of you know uh
fairly well-known producers and network
execs but this was the first group that
i was able to really close
it took a while 20 years 20 years
20 years and um
[Music]
you know i'm i'm grateful that it you
know
that it's here i'm grateful that i do
have the credit um
but it did take a while um and
you know again i'm i'm one of those and
i'm sure many guys and girls who who
have had a lot of near misses with their
scripts
no doubt
no no
and and i and i was fortunate that a lot
of those people really did like my work
that i submitted it was always like we
really like your script not this but
what else do you have and i'd say i have
this and they're like yeah and it just
didn't always sync up you know i did i
did have some really wonderful meetings
with some
you know again some fairly well-known
people but
in the end it just uh
yeah
it this
this this happened finally it was
wonderful
well we always hear about you know
20 under 25 and and you know if you look
at was it steve larsen from the the
trilogy series the girl with the dragon
tattoo yeah i think he was
almost 50 i know he's 50 when he passed
away but yeah he'd been working on
at least one book i'm not sure yeah what
he died i think they they came out after
he died he never even saw the success
right and he had been a journalist and
doing other things and and so
it took a very long time but he was just
very dedicated to he wanted to do it
right yeah there was a gentleman who
just um uh i believe sold he was i think
he's in his 40s
and he had something similar happen uh
where he was like just living hand to
mouth he had a family i believe he's
maybe even irish
and i think he sold
a he wrote a book that sold for
a few million dollars oh wow and he yeah
um
there definitely have been
yeah there there are and i
i certainly don't you know i
i i try to stay young so i don't feel my
age
uh but no it was it was just definitely
you know just just sticking just staying
on the path and and sticking with it and
you know um
[Music]
again you know this isn't like
you know a major studio film but
it's still i i'm i'm proud of where what
happened with it i'm proud that it got
made it's not easy and especially during
the time of kovitz so i definitely take
some pride in that
um
and if it leads to
great things you know that would be
wonderful
um
but i definitely did feel a sense of
accomplishment when you know i got that
paycheck and
you know it's you know the cameras were
rolling it really felt great
it really felt great um and again i hope
to
continue
writing you know and
you know having other stuff produced
we'll see remains to be seen
at what point in the 20 years did you
say i'm not giving up i would say
you know
again i i was i was repped i did have a
literary manager for a long time um who
got my work out there and
i felt like
over the years we got close on a few
things and it was you know it's
obviously like a tease
um
so i never really felt like
you know i was i was ready to give up i
always knew that i i just have a passion
of burning passion to
write so i in my mind i was like look
i'm going to keep doing this
and i will get there
you know i did have some very supportive
people not certainly not ass kissers
telling me you know just keep going
um
and it was encouraging um and i think
really once i got this script and the
other script that i mentioned that's
sort of uh with attachments i think once
those started coming in the last few
years that was like okay
it started feeling like okay this will
eventually happen
it there we're gonna go through well we
obviously went through some discouraging
times in a little bit of the emotional
roller coaster but we were we were able
to i felt eventually we were gonna we
were gonna get there
so um i'd say in the last few years um
i also i also started um
[Music]
about five years ago i started writing
novels as well and i have a i do have a
agent a book agent
um and he's always been very encouraging
and you know he's he has one of our
books that he's shopping now at a lot of
the major publishers
um
uh so
you know it's it's
i feel encouraged by that as well um
[Music]
but yeah i never i never really
i of course there were there are moments
like am i gonna am i gonna quit
do i did i get discouraged yes but i
never felt like i was gonna quit
what did the script sale teach you
humility
perseverance
um
yeah it's uh
when i when i saw that when i saw the
the uh
it was actually deposit
um don't tell my account um
you know i got a little misty-eyed but i
think
i had been through so much
with the you know again
over the years the
you know just
again
people liking your work you're thinking
you were close to something but it was
when it was it was
i hate to say anti-climactic
and i got a little misty-eyed but i was
like okay
this is great but
i i think i'd been i had been at it so
long that i was like you know just it
was it was um
it was definitely a uh
um i definitely was humbled i was i
definitely felt
humbled by it
i really did
humbled in the sense that you stuck with
it because
you loved it or humbled in the sense
that your number was both
yeah i did
i felt um
you know again it was just the it was it
was a lot of years
and
you know it's um
i you know the funny thing is the thing
that went to me is like oh well maybe
this also could be the last time but
i did it
i did it and that was great
that was that was
you know what i took from it
i savored it
um but
i just i just i guess my i wasn't like i
jumped down up and down of this
you know around the house and popped the
champagne cork
as much as i had always envisioned that
right for years like
you know i'm gonna
go
you know ape crap here and and just
you know do cartwheels down the street
risky business right exactly exactly
yeah take my
take my neighbor's porsche out first but
um
no it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't really
like that at all it was again just
anticlimactic in a lot of regards but
again i still left feeling very
just humbled by the time in the
experience and you know and feeling that
perseverance that okay
this is real
i i made it here and so if it's the only
thing that i ever do i still i still
have it on i still have it
you know i still have a credit i still
have it there and that was wonderful
and i hope there's i hope there are more
we'll see
that was my next question
how confident are you that you will get
another movie made
well
i feel that
the other film
[Music]
other script that i have is
you know again timely i
i feel very connected to it i i think
that it's it's got some really terrific
elements in it
um
but
it comes down to dollars and cents
and if the money's there i think we're
in good shape
[Music]
i you know it's it's also just always
gauging people's levels of commitment
in these things and i i feel like
they are committed
but um
yeah i think it comes down to attaching
people and and
and and getting everyone working i think
it's
gelling everyone together in order to
to push it through
that's what i that's what i'm hoping
but at this point
yeah it's a matter of getting getting
the
the investment
into it
you know that one and a half to three
mil it'll take to
to get there and then um
hopefully it's
it leads to
you know
snapping the clap
soon sooner rather than later but we'll
see
so going back to that question i had
said
about if you were going to teach someone
to write a screenplay that sells
the first question probably would be
why do you even want to do it in the
first place because that same person may
not stick with that absolutely for the
20 years but if you love it
yeah if it if it's a burning passion and
it gets you up in the morning and
um you just enjoy the process and you
know the highs and lows that
come with it
then
go for it if it's something where you
know there's nothing wrong with giving
it a try but if it's something where
you're not really it's like anything
else it's
it's what it's a it's malcolm gladwell's
a 10 000 hour rule right where
you
you know you put in your ten thousand
hours i don't see become an expert but
you become pretty proficient at
something
it's just like that
um
but i think also with that ten thousand
hours you really have to love doing it
it really has to get you going and
you know you you really it's it's
essentially it is like uh
uh your mistress
it's my mistress now was my girlfriend
for many years she became my mission
running became my mistress after i got
married and my wife you know my wife
coexists with her pretty well but
[Laughter]
but yeah
it's definitely something you just have
to have an unbridled passion for
and and you seek to
get up every morning
and
it it's there and you it's like and it's
like going to the gym and
working out it's working your riding
muscles every day just going to the gym
going to the writing gym is it the
goldfinch donna tart take her 12 years
to finish that
did it maybe is it a sequel so another
she had another one there i think both
turned into films i know the name
goldfinch was turned into a film but if
i uh maybe but yeah 12 years yeah
that's dedication
and she just loved
she loved the process
absolutely i mean you know there's uh
you know i think william goldman
um he was he was younger when he because
he was a novelist when he was a stat he
established himself probably in his late
20s 30 ish as a but i don't think his
first film was made until he was maybe
in his mid 30s
um
so yeah there's there's definitely
maybe he's not the best example but
there's definitely you know i feel like
writers or
artists or etc out there who are
you know sometimes it just takes them a
little longer to gestate and
find find the story that that is gonna
they're gonna you know make their mark
with or or at least break through
with that
piece of work
did you write every day for 20 years
almost
i would say close to it not i there were
times obviously some weekends
um or when i had my daughter it wasn't
always the easiest thing but there were
times where i'd get up early before she
was awake and especially when she was a
baby um super early and work
now she sleeps late so uh
but no i've i usually i at this at this
stage uh there occasionally i work on
the weekends but generally i confine it
to monday through friday
for the most part so that 20 years you
would get up at quarter to six
not every day but i would i would make i
would make it and then you know i was
working when i was working i i worked at
fox again as a research analyst for a
number of years i would use you know i'd
be up early before i'd have to work um
and then i usually work during my lunch
break
so i tried always try to get in at least
maybe like three hours
um
you know and then
i would i would work sometimes on the
weekend definitely before i was married
um but now i feel like
you know um
i feel like i'm getting hitting most of
my goals during the week
again working smarter not harder
if five years from now pass
and you still haven't made more money
from screenwriting will you keep writing
screenplays
i think it depends
i really enjoyed working on novels um
it's um
you know the great thing about working
novels and having that again we we
talked about the intellectual property
earlier
that
so many of so many of the films that are
being made now um are based on ip
and now that i have
really two
properties that are ip um
i feel that
you know and i actually i do have
confidence that one of them will be sold
soon
hopefully both but one i think
again unlike wood
is close
um
i would love to turn
both of those into
films
um
but we'll see
um i
will always be writing
you know i'm a senior
um
because i still need to work and pay my
bills uh
i'm a senior copywriter in um at a
company out here in la
so i am always writing uh no matter what
copy novels scripts um and they're all
very different
not to take anything not to be undone
but it's still for me the process is
still
is copywriting novels scripts
you still need to do your research you
still need to have a great headline or a
log line or
you know
and you need to have structure to what
you're writing it really so much of
writing
does follow that those those that
similar pattern and that's how i work
anyway
um
so i'm satiated with the
with being able to write every day now
which is wonderful
um
that said
yeah i would never if if an opportunity
came up to write a great story or if i
found a time
to
develop a script that i thought would
make a really great film
absolutely
um
so i would never i would never not do it
i think though
you know at this point um
[Music]
the movie business has become
again it's it's just changed so
drastically even the last five years
so um
i feel like
again a lot of writers
are again writing books or back and
forth or writing tv
or are back and forth between novels and
tv and film they're bouncing all around
so
but i think they're picking their
opportunities as they come up rather
than just being a screenwriter straight
screenwriter and i think writers are
diversifying
all the time
which is great
um
so yeah i i think creativity is
creativity i think if you're either
you're writing for a
you know health and wellness brand or
you're working for um
you're writing a novel about um world
war ii i think they all sort of
you know feed into each other
with the process
and
so yeah i know that's sort of the long
answer but no i would i would completely
be
open to it but i also feel like i have
a whole array of other
um
creative projects in my portfolio at
this point so if it lends itself to that
then absolutely
right and you're absolutely right i
think you said that either before the
interview or or during just that so many
adaptations are you know are
appearing i mean what the hillbilly
allergies
right um
the queen's gambit was based on a book
from um actually interesting story about
that gentleman he it was published in
1983 and he died in 1984. oh and now
it's being made almost 40 years later oh
wow so it's it's definitely um
[Music]
you know a um
you know
there there's there is
you know a tremendous push for again
the adaptation and basing
you know current material and previous
material again whether it's graphic
novel comic novel like we just discussed
podcast anything art a news article
magazine article
and um
it's for for whatever reason i feel like
the the folks who are who are in
who are at a lot of these companies or
these production companies who still
have sway
they feel that that it there's some
there's an air of legitimacy to putting
that forward and there's not as many
original
series
you know or ideas really being put forth
like they used to be
yeah and i don't know if it's just
because our attention spans are so much
shorter so like novels used to be such a
thing and letter writing and all that
and now right okay if that's actually a
success then we can turn it into i don't
know it's yeah it's it's it's really
true it's really true it's um
[Music]
they uh
movie books are are actually the the i
believe what i read recently that books
are being sold at uh still at a pretty
high rate uh their their book sales are
up obviously when the pandemic certainly
helped out and i don't know many of
those are ebooks versus actual hard
copies but
um they're still reading people are
still reading and i think that there is
so much material out there
uh that they're drawing from and
oftentimes they view
certain material like i said as a
legitimate source there's already that
built-in audience
even if it's 5 000 people who have read
it it's still
they and it was it's made by an imprint
you know one of
you know harpercollins 300 imprints and
it's small it's got us but it's still
it still has a really good hook and
it will
it it has a built-in fan base to an
extent
and then they decide okay well we can we
can make this into a film i don't know
i don't i again i don't know the mindset
i think again it is it does have
something to do with
they want to max obviously like any
other business they want to maximize
their profit and they see if they
already have a built-in fan base
that's going only going to
you know increase sales and and it's you
know
it makes sense right and barfly was that
with mickey rourked wasn't that based on
i may have been uhkowski okay it may
have been i wasn't sure yes it was okay
it was may stoner bukowski yes then
bukowski wrote about it in hollywood i
think if it's the same film yeah and he
talked about his process so yeah
yeah
yeah i think i don't know very
colorfully described yeah exactly
exactly yeah he was a he was a character
in fact totem i think as well about his
jobs yeah with matt dylan
and lily yeah exactly so you know it's
been going on for a while but yeah there
was that built-in audience and then
absolutely there we go absolutely and
and you again you see like hillbilly lg
or
um i know where the crawdad saying is
going to be coming out uh that's all got
major studios attached to it um but
you're talking about you know however
many hundreds of thousands or millions
of copies sold
and people are gonna say hey you know i
love that book i'm i'm
you know subscribe or
when we do go back to theaters you know
they'll oh yeah they'll they'll go
they'll go pay to see it
for sure yeah i hope that opportunity is
still around i hope so too i hope so too